SUBCOMMITTEE FOR HEARING ON
STATE ADMINISTRATION FOR THIS
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE PLEASE
COME TO ROOM FOUR FOUR SEVEN
TODAY IN FOUR FOUR SEVEN THE
PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA ARE
APPEARING IN PERSON AND REMOTELY
USING ONLINE TECHNOLOGY WE ARE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THIS HEARING BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE
THE PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
SHOULD THERE SHOULD ALSO BE ON
THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE WATCHING
OVER THE INTERNET. THE PHONE
NUMBER IS TOLL FREE 877-692-8957
THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR SEVEN
IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS
PLEASE CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT 916-319-2099
AND THE STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU WE ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO
PROVIDE WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE HEARING PLEASE SEND YOUR
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO BUDGETS OF
FOUR AT ASM DOT CA DODGY OVIH.
WITH THAT- MINUTES AFTER THIS
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. WE WANT TO
HEAR. LAST WEEK. THIS AREA.
WICKS HERE. THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU TO OUR CHAIR OF BUDGET WHO
IS JOIING US TODAY AS WELL
THANK WELCOME WE HAVE SEVEN
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR-
WE WILL HAVE TO VOTES. ARE VOTE
ONLY ISSUES ARE ONE AND THREE TO
SEVEN IS THERE A MOTION. SEVEN
THANK YOU. TO WE NEED TO CALL
THE ROLL LET'S CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE CARILLO HI. COOPER LACKEY
. HI NAZARIAN WICKS ARE. ON NOW
WE WILL MOVE TO VOTE ONLY ON
ISSUE NUMBER TWO IS THERE A
MOTION. SO YEAH A SECOND. A ROLL
CALL PLEASE CARILLO HI COOPER
LACKEY. NAZARIAN WHAT. THANK YOU
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO- WE WILL
BEGIN BY HEARING ISSUE NUMBER
TWO ON HOUSING SPENDING OVERVIEW
OUR PANELISTS WILL INCLUDE- MISS
LOU THAT'S WHAT I LISAK THAT AND
CHRIS COOK LET'S BEGIN. IS- AS
WELL AS ONLINE. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS NUTAN FOR
LISTED THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- I WILL BE SHARING THE
SCREEN ALTHOUGH I DON'T SEE MY
SHARE OPTION ACTIVATED AT THIS
MOMENT. CAN WE PLEASE PROVIDE
WITH MISS BROWN WAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THANK YOU.
HERE WE GO TO DINNER WITH ME ONE
MOMENT. THANK YOU I BELIEVE YOU
CANNOT SEE THE HANDOUT. SO I'VE
BEEN ASKED BY THE COMMITTEE TO
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF RECENT
BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS PROVIDED TO
EACH CD AND THE DEPARTMENT'S
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT FUNDS.
THE INTENT OF THIS PRESENTATION
IS TO PROVIDE CONTEXT TO THE SUB
COMMITTEE CONSIDERS THE
GOVERNOR'S TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE HOUSING PROPOSALS.
LATER IN THE SYNGENTA. I'M NOT
AVAILABLE IN THE WEBSITE. I'M SO
BRIEFLY THREE WE HIGHLIGHT THE
MISSION OF EACH CITY TO PROMOTE
SAFE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
STRONG COMMUNITIES BY
ADMINISTERING HOUSING PROGRAMS
MIDDLEMISS HARLEM ONE MOMENT
PLEASE CAN WE HIRE HER VOLUME OR
IF IT'S THE ROOM IT SOUNDS A
LITTLE LOW. OR ECHOING. PLEASE
CONTINUE AND IF YOU CAN MAYBE
PROJECT A LITTLE BIT MORE INTO
YOUR MICROHABITAT HARD TIME
HEARING YOU. ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU. SO THIS LIST HIGHLIGHTS-
BRIEFLY THE MISSION OF EACH CD
TO ADMINISTER HOUSING POLICIES
AND PROGRAMS AND DEVELOPING
BUILDING CODES AND REGULATIONS
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING FINANCING AGENCY- WHO
HAS A MISSION TO FINANCE HEALTH
ACROSS THE STATE WHILE THE
STATUTORILY INDEPENDENT ENTITY
FOR BUDGETING PURPOSES IT IS
DISPLAYED WITH IN THE EACH CD
BUDGET. TO THE NEXT PAGE OF YOUR
HANDOUT PROVIDES ANY LOOK AT
FUNDING WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT IN
RECENT YEARS HISTORICALLY
PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED BY EACH CD
HAVE BEEN FUNDED THROUGH SPECIAL
FUNDS LARGELY CONSISTING OF BOND
PROCEEDS AND FROM FEW REVENUE AS
WELL AS FEDERAL FUNDING. YU SEE
THIS REFLECTED IN THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FISCAL YEAR ON THE
FIGURE. BEGINNING IN NINETEEN
TWENTY FEDERAL FUNDING-
SCREENING BEGAN IN TWENTY
GENERAL FUND PUTTING WITH EACH
CITY INCREASE AT THE STATE TOOK
A LARGER ROLE IN ADDRESSING THE
STATE'S HOUSING NEEDS. THE
LIGHTEST YOU HAVE GREAT YOU SEE
EACH CITY HAS ALSO RECEIVED A
LARGE INFUSIONS OF FEDERAL
FUNDING RELATED TO THE COPA
NINETEEN CANTIK. OVERALL THE
FEDERAL CODE NINETEEN RELATED
FUNDING AND THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THE GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATIONS
IN RECENT YEARS HAPPENED ONE
TIME OR TEMPORARY IN NATURE. THE
GOVERNOR'S TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE BUDGET PROPOSES A
TOTAL OF THREE POINT FOUR
BILLION AND ONE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED POSITIONS THIS IS AN
INCREASE OF ROUGHLY FORTY
POSITION AND IT DECREASE OF NINE
BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE PRIOR
YEAR. AGAIN MOSTLY DUE TO THE
SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME FUNDING
PROVIDED IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. BUDGET WHICH IS NOW
EXPIRING. THANKS HE- WENT OKAY.
THIS IS YOUR GENERALLY CAPTURES
THEM MAJOR DISCRETIONARY
SPENDING ACTIONS WITHIN EACH
CITY KELLY TOOK THE IN RECENT
YEARS IMPORTANTLY THIS FIGURE
DOES NOT INCLUDE A FINE FIRST
THE FUNDING FOR JUST AUTHORIZED
BOND PROCEEDS- REACHING FEDERAL
FUNDING THESE HOUSING PROGRAMS
SUPPORT MANY ASPECTS OF WHAT IT
TAKES TO GET A UNIT OF HOUSING
BUILT FOR EXAMPLE SOME PROGRAMS
FOCUSED ON PREPARING LAND FOR
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT WHILE OTHERS
ARE FOCUSED ON PREPARING OUR
BUILDING AND A PARKING TICKET
HOUSING DIRECTLY. PURSUANT TO
THE COMMITTEE'S REQUEST OF OUR
OFFICE WE REQUESTED INFORMATION
FROM EACH DVD CAN A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
IMPLEMENTATION IS GOING ON SOME
OF THE KEY PROGRAMS HIGHLIGHTED
IN THIS TABLE WE PRESENT THE
INFORMATION IN THE NEXT SECTION
OF THE HANDOUT WELL THE
INFORMATION ADDRESSES AND KEY
QUESTIONS OUR OFFICE IN THE
LEGISLATURE HAS HAD IN THE PAST
AND WE ALSO RAISE NEW QUESTIONS
FOR THE COMMITTEE. WE HOPE THAT
THE PACKAGING OF INFORMATION
SORT OF THE FORTY TODAY IT WILL
BE A STEP FORWARD IN YOUR. ON
GOING OVERSIGHT OF THESE
PROGRAMS. WE COVER SIX KEY
PROGRAMS IN THE SECTION TO HAND
OUT HOME HE- HOUSING ACCELERATOR
PROGRAM. THE INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM THE
JOKES ON A FARM WORKER HOUSING
PROGRAM THE NEXT INCOME PROGRAM
FINALLY THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM.
IN ALL THESE CASES WE PROVIDE A
BRIEF PROGRAM DESCRIPTION.
SUMMARIZE RECENT BUDGET ACTIONS
AND DESCRIBE HOW AWARDED FUNDING
HAVE BEEN DISTRIBUTED ACROSS THE
STATE. IS THE TIME I WILL ONLY
PERCENT A FEW KEY TAKEAWAYS THAT
EACH PROGRAM HOWEVER I CAN GO
INTO FURTHER DETAIL SHOULD
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS. FOR
COMPLETE WHICH FELL OFF THE
PROJECT GROUP HE AND PROVIDES
FOR THE ACQUISITION OF
PROPERTIES CAN BE CONVERTED
REHABILITATED INTO PERMANENT
HOUSING OR IN FROM HOUSING. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS AUTHORIZED
FUNDING FOR THREE FISCAL YEARS.
ONE MILLION AUTHORIZED IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE HAS BEEN FULLY
AWARDED IN EACH CITY ANTICIPATE
IT CREATING NEARLY FIVE THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED UNITS. YOU CAN SEE
THAT MOST OF THE AWARDS HAVE
BEEN PROVIDED IN THE BAY AREA
AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY. THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
FORTY ONLY BEEN PARTIALLY
DISTRIBUTED BUT WE PRESENT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THOSE AWARDS SO
FAR WHICH LARGELY MEMBERS OF THE
DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS FOR THE
PRIOR AROUND. THE HOUSING
ACCELERATOR PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED IN THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET AS A ONE TIME
PROGRAM TO FILL IN FUNDING GAPS.
SPECIAL ALREADY PROJECTS THAT
HAVE. RECEIVED FUNDING FROM
OTHER HUD PROGRAMS OR STILL
WAITING TO ACCESS LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDITS. JUST OVER
HALF OF THE FUNDING HAS BEEN
AWARDED AND ABOUT TWO THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED UNITS ARE
ANTICIPATED TO BE CREATED AS A
RESULT OF THIS PORTION OF THE-
FOR THE FUNDING OF
OVERWHELMINGLY CONTENT BAY AREA
AND OTHER NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES. THE INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM
PROVIDES FUNDING FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS TO
FACILITATE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
INFILL HOUSING WHAT THE PROGRAM
HISTORICALLY BEEN FUNDED YOU CAN
FIND IT PROCEEDS FROM
PROPOSITION ONE FEET OF
PROPOSITION ONE THE NINETEEN
TWENTY AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET. I PROVIDED THE PROGRAM
WITH GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATIONS
IN ALL THE REWARDED FUNDING IS
ANTICIPATED TO SUPPORT THE
CREATION OF JUST OVER THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND UNITS. IMPORTANTLY
THE NINETEEN- THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION HAD EIGHTY NINETY
MILLION NINETY MILLION SET ASIDE
FOR SMALL JURISDICTIONS IN THE
BOTTOM RIGHT HAND CORNER OF THIS
SECTION OF THE OF THE HAND ON
PAGE EIGHT. YOU SEE THAT THE
SATISFIED HAS NOT THE INTENDED.
A SIGNIFICANTLY SHIFTING HOW
FUNDING IS DISTRIBUTED IN THE
PROGRAM REALLY FOCUSING ON MUCH
SMALLER MORE RURAL COUNTIES. AN
IMPORTANT THE GOVERNOR IS
PROPOSING A SIGNIFICANT A
CONDITION FOR THIS PROGRAM
PROVIDING AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION OVER TWO FISCAL
YEARS. NEXT WE DISCUSS THE JOKES
ARE NOT FARMWORKER HOUSING
PROGRAM. ADJUSTER NOT PROGRAM
FINANCES THE CONSTRUCTION
REHABILITATION AND ACQUISITION
OF OWNER OCCUPIED AND RENTAL
UNITS FOR FARMWORKER HOUSING.
AWARD CENTER TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY ARE EXPECTED TO PROVIDE
NEARLY ONE THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
UNITS A FARM WORKER HOUSING THE
DISTRIBUTION OF AWARDS GENERALLY
ALIGNS WITH AREAS OF THE STATE
THAT HAVE A LARGE AGRICULTURAL
SECTORS. THE MIX INCOME A
PROGRAM FINANCES CONSTRUCTION OF
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING FOR
CALIFORNIANS EARNING BETWEEN 30%
AND A HUNDRED AND 20% OF THE
AREA MEDIAN INCOME. THE PROGRAMS
OF NESTOR BY CALLIE CAFE WILL
ASK US SOURCE OF ONGOING FUNDING
XPG REVENUES. IN SOMERS GENERAL
FUND APPLICATIONS HAVE MATCHED
OR SIGNIFICANTLY EXCEEDED AT IT
YOU REVENUES RECEIVED BY THE
PROGRAM. IT'S NOT A PARTIAL
DOES. OF AWARDS TO DATE KELLY
CHECK THING DISSIPATES ABOUT
FIVE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED TOTAL
UNITS OVERWHELMING THESE UNITS
WOULD BE LOCATED IN THE BAY
AREA. HERE AGAIN THE GOVERNOR
FOR PUTTING ADDITIONAL. OF TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND OVER TWO FISCAL
YEARS. AND THE FINAL PROGRAM AND
THAT WILL HIGHLIGHT IN THIS
HANDOUT IF THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING INDISPUTABLE COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM. IN THIS PROGRAM IS
ADMINISTERED BY THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL OF THE
IMPLEMENTED BY EACH CD I'M
FUNDING FOR LAND USE ON HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION AND LAND
PRESERVATION PROJECTS THAT
SUPPORT INTEL INTENSE
DEVELOPMENT. THE STARKLY BEEN
FUNDED BY A PORTION OF CAP AND
TRADE AUCTION PROCEEDS. EQUALITY
RECORDED FUNDS ARE ANTICIPATED
TO SUPPORT THE CREATION OF A
OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND UNITS
MOSTLY IN THE BAY AREA AND LOS
ANGELES HERE AGAIN THE
GOVERNORSHIP CAUSING AN
ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATION THREE
HUNDRED MILLION IN GENERAL FUND
TO BE THE FIRST TIME THE PROGRAM
RECEIVED A GENERAL FUND.
APPROPRIATION AND SO IN CLOSING
THIS FINAL TABLE SUMMARIZES THE
GOVERNOR'S TWENTY TWO NINETY TWO
TWENTY THREE BUDGET PROPOSALS.
AND THE RECENTLY RELEASED
STATEWIDE HOUSING PLAN IN SOME
CASES THE GOVERNOR FOR CLOTHING
SIGNIFICANT APPLICATIONS TO
PROGRAMS WE'VE DISCUSSED IN THIS
HANDOUT IN OTHER CASES AS WELL
KNOWN YOU FUNDING IS PROPOSED
UNDERSTANDING HOW MAJOR. PRIOR
AUTHORIZATIONS THE FUNDING ARE
BEING IMPLEMENTED COULD INFORM
THE LEGISLATURE'S DECISION AS A
CONSEQUENCE. BUDGET BEFORE IT.
THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD
DESCRIBE THESE PROPOSALS AND
DISCUSS THE HOUSING PLANT NEXT
ON YOUR AGENDA THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS BROWN THIS IS MISTER
AUSTINONLINE. IF YOU MISTER
OLDER I'M HERE. PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU- WELL- I'M GOING TO
SPEAK TO THE STATE WHAT HOUSING
PLAN AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO- JUST
LAST WEEK- IF YOU RELEASE THE
STATE WHAT HAPPENED PLAN AND
WHILE I'M DOING A HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW HERE TODAY I ENCOURAGE
ANYONE WHO IS INTERESTED ACCESS
PLAN IN DIGITAL FORMAT EACH OF
THESE WEBSITES. ARE EIGHTY HAVE
LEVERAGE OUR DIGITAL TOOLS
PROVIDE WHAT WE CONSIDER TO BE A
DYNAMIC LIVING STATE WHITE HOUSE
IMPORTANT WITH INTERACTIVE
FEATURES THAT WILL BE UPDATED AS
NEW DATA ENTRY OF THE BILL THAT
WILL HELP THE STATE TRACK OUR.
PROGRESS TOWARD OUR GOAL. EIGHT
IT MAY BE EASY. UNDERSTAND FOR
ALL INCLUDING CALIFORNIA WHO
MAYBE USED TO HELP. WHAT PLAN
SIXTY TWO EVEN HELP HELP UNDER
THE PROBLEM AND HOW WE GOT HERE
THE HOUSING NEEDS. HOW WE WILL
HOLD OURSELVES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE FOR HOW.
IT HOW WE TRACK OUR PROGRESS IN
THE TALKS. ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT ELEMENTS OF THE PLAN
IS THE DATA DASHBOARD WHICH CAN
BE USED BY ELECTED OFFICIALS.
THE MEDIA OR ANY INTERESTED
PERSON THINKING HOUSING INSIGHTS
AT THE STATE REGIONAL
CALCULABLE. WE ARE REQUIRED TO
INCLUDE DATA TABLES WITH HOUSING
FACT SPECTACULAR. ALWAYS
PREVIOUSLY BEEN EXCEL DOCUMENTS
HIDDEN IN THE AND- THE SIX
DIGITAL PLAN ALLOWS FOR AN
INTERACTIVE EXPERIENCE. THE DATA
IN A WAY THAT COULD GET. ALL
RECOGNIZING THAT BETTER DATA
LEADS TO BETTER OUTCOMES. IT HAS
ALSO RELEASED A TEN YEAR HOUSING
DATA STRATEGY AS PART OF THIS
YEAR. THIS IS THE FIRST HOUSING
SPECIFIC DATA STRATEGY IN THE
NATION. IN CALIFORNIA THE PATH
TO BE THE LEADER IN DATA DRIVEN
HEALTH. THE LANDING PAGE FAR
PLANNER WEBSITE ALSO PROVIDES
EASY ACCESS TO OTHER RESOURCES.
INCLUDING EIGHTEEN LATEST ANNUAL
REPORT. OUR COMPLETE PROGRAM
DASHBOARD. HOMELESS DATA
INTEGRATION SYSTEM ANY ANNUAL
PROGRESS REPORT YEAH. AFTER THE
PLAY ITSELF. THE STATE WOULD
HOUSING PLAN LEAVES OUT OF
FIFTEEN TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THREE EVIL AND
AFFORDABLE. THE STATE WORKS
TOWARDS THE THREE OBJECTIVES TO
ACHIEVE. ONE CALIFORNIANS IN
THEIR HOMES TO PRODUCE FOR
PORTABLE CLIMATE SMART HOUSING
AND THREE CONTINUE TO ACT WITH
URGENCY TO ADDRESS- THE PLANET
ALSO THE BUNDLE FACT THAT HIGH
HOUSING COSTS THREATENED
CALIFORNIA. FOR EXAMPLE THE TOP
FIVE MOST COMMON OCCUPATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA THEY LEFT IN THE WE
JUST NEED TO ASK FOR HELP.
EXAMPLE HOME HEALTHY OFTEN
CHARACTER PEOPLE CANNOT CURE
THEMSELVES MAKES HAPPILY JUST
NEEDED REPORTER ONE BEDROOM
RENTAL UNITS STATE. OUR HOUSING
COSTS PRACTICES HALF CENTURY IN
THE MAKING AFTER DECADES OF
UNDER PRODUCTION SUPPLIES FAR
BEHIND BEAT IN HOUSING AFTER
SCHOOL. RESULT MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH MAKE THE HARD
DECISIONS ABOUT PAYING FOR EXTRA
FOOD TO HELP THEIR CHILD CARE
AND TRANSPORTATION. DIRECTLY
IMPACTING QUALITY OF LIFE STATE.
ONE IN THREE IN THE STATE
DOESN'T EARN ENOUGH MONEY TO
MEET BASIC HOUSING. IT WOULD
HAVE PLANS. TO HELP CALIFORNIA'S
HOW SEVERELY NEW CONSTRUCTION OF
HOUSING LEGAL FAMILY AND
ENFORCEMENT LAGGED BEHIND ITS
WORK LEVERAGES THE LIKE FOR THE
BEHIND THE NUMBER OF UNITS
NEEDED. HELP ME. WHEN ALSO WILL
COME. UNDERSTAND THE
CONTRIBUTING FACTORS TO HELP
GEORGE EXPLAINS OUR FUTURE
HELPING. IN ORDER TO MEET THAT
FEATURE HOUSING NEEDS AT A
MINIMUM THE STATE IS STATUTORILY
REQUIRED TO PLAN FOR TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION HOMES OVER THE ROOF
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS.
AT LEAST ONE MILLION OF THOSE
HOMES MUST MEET THE NEED TO
LOWER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. THIS IS
MORE THAN DOUBLE PRIOR POLITICS
. A TEAM OF THE IN ITS
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE- THIS IS
NOT A THEORETICAL ACADEMIC
TARGET THIS IS THE MINIMUM
AMOUNT OF STATUTORILY REQUIRED
ASK YOU THAT MUST BE PLANNED FOR
CALIFORNIA. HOW THE PLACE MUST
COME WITH STRATEGIES TO MOVE
STRAIGHT. HOUSING AT HOUSING TO
HELP. THIS CHANGEABLE NAVIGABLE
ESSENTIAL THE BRANDING DRIVING
CALVET. FORTUNATELY STUDENTS ARE
TAKING MANY STEPS TO ADDRESS
THIS CRISIS WE HIGHLIGHT SOME OF
THOSE BROUGHT THE WHAT WE'RE
DOING SECTION IN THE PLAN AND
THAT'S WE'LL SEE THE RECENT
HOUSING LEGISLATION PATH AND
OTHER STATE EFFORTS UNDER WAY
IT'S THE COMBINATION OF LAWS AND
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FLAWS
THAT WILL MOVE US FROM JUST
PLAIN ACTUALLY BUILDING MORE
THAN TWO POINT FIVE MORE. AFTER
A FEW. OFTEN TAKING UP IN
JANUARY TWENTY NINETEEN
GOVERNANCE OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HAVE. PASSED BY
SEVENTEEN HOUSING RELATED.
SEQUEL REFORM BILL. THE
STREAMLINED EXTRA PORTABLE
CLIMATE SMART HEALTHY. IT
CREATED A ONE STOP SHOP FOR
FUNDING TO EXPECT THE
DEVELOPMENT AFFORDABLE ORAL
HOUSING SOMEONE DALY SPEAKING
FOUR THIRTY FOUR. HEDIS CREATED
A NEW HOUSE ACCOUNTABLE UNIT
THIS BOOK AGREEMENTS. HOLD THE
TO THE HOUSING OBLIGATIONS. THE
STATE IS PATHWAYS LEADING RETURN
EVICTION PROTECTIONS AND ONCE
RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND
FORECLOSURE PREVENTION PROGRAMS
HE CALIFORNIANS IN THEIR HOMES.
IN THE STATE IS ALSO WERE TO
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
THE DEVELOPMENT OF TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF FOUR HUNDRED
MINUTES. IN RECENT YEARS.
OCTOBER POINT ON IT JULY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IT HAS AWARDED OVER
EIGHT BILLION. DOLLARS IN
SUPPORT OF THE DEVELOPMENT FOR
FORTY SIX THOUSAND. HOUSING
UNITS. IN THE STATE IS NOT
SCHEDULED TO WORK IN ADDITIONAL
SIX POINT FIVE BILLION. DOLLARS
FOR HBCU DEVELOPMENT AND
OPERATIONS OVER THE COURSE OF
THE REMAINDER OF TWENTY TWENTY
IT. AND LASTLY THE PLAN OUTLINED
SOME INDICATORS THAT THE STATE
WILL GIVE TO TRACK YOUR PROGRESS
WITH PRODUCING MORE AFFORDABLE
AND ACCESSIBLE CALIFORNIA. IF
YOU WANT I THINK SHOULD BE USED
TO GUIDE HOUSING POLICY BUT IT
WILL NOT SOLVE THE HOUSING
CRISIS OVERNIGHT. NO ONE
SOLUTION THANK COULD. ALL THE
STATE IS ALREADY UNLOCKED ROOM
WITH HOUSING AFFORDABILITY OUR
STATE GOVERNMENT NOTHING WOULD
ALONG. WE NEED THE HELP AND
SUPPORT OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT REAL ESTATE
DEVELOPERS AND LENDERS HOME
BUILDERS AND DESIGNERS AND ALL
CALIFORNIA. THE REPORT WILL
CONTINUE TO BUILD ON OUR CURRENT
ACTION CALL IN OTHER HOUSING
STAKEHOLDERS TO MEET. OUR THREE
AFTER MAKING THE- OBJECTIVES OF
KEEPING CALIFORNIANS IN THE HOME
. ANYTHING MORE AFFORDABLE FOR
SMART HOW. IT CONTINUED ACT
WITH- URGENCY THE WILL. THANK
YOU FOR ME TO SPEAK THE PLAN
KNOW WHAT YOU WITH THE COUNTY
PLANS I BUT I CAN TO- FOR THE
PROPOSAL SEPARATE ITEM I AM
HAPPY TO ANSWERING ON THE
INSTITUTIONAL. WE HEAR FROM. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE PLACE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRIS COOK WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME BUT AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I DO WANT TO OPEN IT UP TO OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IF THEY HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OF MS WITH. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- I WANT TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS COMMITMENT
TO FUNDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS SINCE HE TOOK
OFFICE I KNOW- HE PUT TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN LAST YEAR-
THE FIRST TIME EVER A MULTI YEAR
I'M FUNDING TO SUPPORT
HOMELESSNESS RESPONSE SYSTEM.
AND IT CONTINUES FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION INVESTMENTS IN THE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT I KNOW
THIS YEAR PROPOSAL HAS ABOUT TWO
BILLION IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING-
AND I ALSO I'VE I APPRECIATE THE
TEN YEAR- STATE WHAT HOUSING
PLAN THAT THAT WAS RELEASED I
KNOW AS PART OF THAT PLAN- AND I
THINK. MOST OF US KNOW THIS IT
CALLS FOR TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
TOTAL HOUSING UNITS TO. TO MEET
THE DEMAND- WHICH INCLUDES OVER
ONE MILLION LOW AND EXTREMELY
LOW INCOME HOUSING UNITS. I
THINK WE ALL KNOW TO END
HOMELESSNESS AND ADDRESS THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS WE
NEED A LONG TERM SPENDING
COMMITMENT- TEN YEARS WAS VERY
CLEAR ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES TO
ENSURE PROGRESS I KNOW MANY OF
US WENT ON A HOUSING TOUR. THIS
PAST FALL- WE WERE ALL OVER THE
STATE FROM CHICO TOOK CONCORD TO
INLAND EMPIRE FRESNO SALINAS IN
MANY OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE-
AND WHAT WE HEARD FROM OVER AND
OVER AGAIN IS THE FACT THAT
THERE IS NO ON GOING FUNDING
STREAM FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING-
AND IT'S VERY HARD TO PLAN WE
GET ONE TIME. MONIES AND
OBVIOUSLY THE GOVERNOR HAS MADE
GREAT STRIDES TO- PROVIDE THE
MONEY THAT HE HAS IN THE
CAPACITY THAT HE HAS- BUT I ALSO
BELIEVE THAT OUR BUDGET IS OUR
VALUES AND THE FACT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE. ONGOING CONSISTENT
FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TO ME SAYS THAT THAT'S AN AREA
WHERE WE NEED TO BE FOCUSED- AS
WELL AS THE IMPORTANT
ACCOUNTABLE ABILITY MEASURES TO
GO AFFECTS YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE
OUR TAXPAYERS KNOW THAT THEY'RE
GETTING A STRONG R. O. Y. ON
THEIR INVESTMENT THEY WERE.
PROBLEM WAS NOT- I WANTED TO ASK
EIGHT CD- IT IF YOU ALL HAVE
DONE A TEN YEAR FUNDING STRATEGY
TO FINANCE THE ONE MILLION LOW
INCOME HOUSING UNITS NEEDED-
CALLED FOR IN THE STATEWIDE
HOUSING PLAN. THAT'S NOT A PART
OF THE STATE WHAT HEALTHY PLAN
BUT WE DO HAVE. A CALENDAR OF
OUR ARE SCHEDULED INVESTMENTS OR
NOTICES MONEY AVAILABLE GIVE
THEM ON A WEBSITE LIKE I
MENTIONED. SIX POINT FIVE
BILLION IS STILL SCHEDULED TO BE
RELEASED AND AVAILABLE- JUST
THIS COMING CALENDAR YEAR. OFF
FOLLOWING THE EIGHT BILLION IN
PREVIOUS YEARS SO- OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE IMPLEMENTERS OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT- AFT. THE THERE IS
STILL FUNDING FOR THE- IN THIS
IN THIS NEW TERM. AND THAT'S OUR
FOCUS ON THE COURSE OF THE CRAP
DIRE NEEDING REPORTS OUT OF.
THANK YOU ALL I AM COMMITTED TO
FIGURE OUT ALONG TERM FUND FOR
THE HOUSING. I KNOW MANY MY
COLLEAGUES ARE NOT SOMETHING I
KNOW WILL BE WORKING OUT. A BOTH
IN THIS COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
AND- HOUSING COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU REST WICKS. APPRECIATE YOUR
PERSPECTIVE BEING THE CHAIR OF
HOUSING AS WELL AS- BEING IN
THIS COMMITTEE TO- TRULY IT ALSO
ADVOCATE FOR. THE BUDGET BEING A
REFLECTION OF OUR VALUES- MR OLD
SAID I ALSO HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS FOR YOU AS WELL- ARE
YOU SEE ARE THERE ANY OTHER
PROJECTS BESIDES HOTEL. TELLS
BEING USED WITH- HOME HE DOLLARS
. ABSOLUTELY AND IN THE FIRST
ROUND AS WELL- YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY THAT ONE IS I THINK A
DISTRESSED ASSETS LAST YEAR THAT
WAS A COMMON PURCHASE. BUT EVEN
LAST YEAR THERE WAS QUITE A BIT
OF- ASSEMBLY COMMERCIAL- MODULAR
HOUSING. I WILL STILL SEEING
THAT PLAY OUT IN OUR FUNDING
COMMITMENTS. WITH THE- PEOPLE
THERE STILL ARE LOOK HEALTHY
GOOD LOOKING PURCHASE. SOME
CASES YOU'RE SAYING THE
ACQUISITION OF EXISTING MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING. OF USING THOSE-
THE PHONE THIRTY NEXT TO SIR-
THAT THE PERSON'S EXPERIENCE IN
BUSINESS HOUSEHOLD EXPENSES HOME
OFFICE OVERSEEING A PRETTY GOOD
I MEAN I'M SORRY CAN YOU REPEAT
THAT LAST BIT. TO SPEAK BACK UP
LIKE MAYBE A. MINUTE AFTER. WHAT
YOU SAID. WE ARE LOOKING YES WE
ARE STILL A QUITE QUITE A FEW
ISSUES. OF THE OLD WILL USE THAT
WITHIN HOME AGAIN WE AND ROUND
OF. OUR HOTEL IN MOST WERE A
DISTRESS ASSETS OF COURSE LAST
YEAR- TAKE A- TO BE SO THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR. A STATE
OF THE- FUNDING BUT EEING.
QUITE A BIT OF ADDITIONAL
ADAPTIVE REUSE AFTER THIS REPORT
FOR PROPERTIES MODULAR HOUSING.
AND THE LIKE AND- YOU CAN SEE
SOME BREAKDOWNS OF WHAT THAT
THAT IS ON OUR DASHBOARD OR DATA
DASHBOARD THAT IS AVAILABLE.
THANK YOU AND DO YOU SEE. THE
GETTING MARKS. AS THE QUALITY OF
THE HOTELS AND MOTELS AVAILABLE-
ARE NEEDING MORE REHABILITATION
AND WHAT IS THE AVERAGE COST.
WELL THAT'S THAT'S A GOOD THAT'S
A GREAT QUESTION SO- THE AVERAGE
COST IS PROBABLY. YOU KNOW WELL
I THINK WHAT YOU'RE PROBABLY
ASKING IS WHAT LOOKS LIKE THE
PER UNIT COST YOU BECAUSE OF
COURSE THOSE COSTS. CAN VARY
DEPENDING UPON THE REGION AND
THE DEMAND- AND YOU'RE RIGHT ON
THE NATURE OF THE HOTEL THE LESS
WE ABILITY THE GREATER THE
PURCHASE PRICE MIGHT BE ON THE
FRONT END. AND LEFT
REHABILITATION YOU MIGHT SEE ON
THE BACK WE NEED TO THE BACK AND
SO YOU ALL THERE THERE'S A
VARIETY RIGHT AND THEN THE LOWER
QUALITY OF THE HOTEL. MOTEL
MIGHT REQUIRE A LITTLE BIT MORE
REHABILITATION FOR. LOOKING SO.
PEOPLE ARE ACROSS. THOUGH AGAIN
. ALTHOUGH PUBLICLY ABOUT WHAT
THOSE COSTS ARE GOING TO BRING
BASIS AND WHAT WHAT WORK WHAT WE
BE YOUR HOUSE IF. THANK OUR-
IT'S FAR LESS THAN CONSTRUCT
PROCESS WITH THE COUNTY FOR THE
NEW. PATIENT DEPENDING UPON THE
REGION OR ANY PART OF THE METHOD
RIGHT MODULAR HOUSING ME OFF A
LITTLE BIT LESS. YOU SEE ANY
ANYWHERE AS LOW AS A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND PER UNIT UP TO
THREE OR THOUSAND DOLLAR UNIT.
WE OFFER. HOME CREATED ANYWHERE
IN BETWEEN WHICH IS STILL QUITE
QUITE LEFT THE. NEW CONSTRUCTION
. WHERE'S THAT BURIES PROJECTS
PROJECT IN REGION FIVE WE- THANK
YOU BYE IF YOU CAN I. IF YOU
PLEASE BE SO AS TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION WITHOUT ME HAVING TO GO
TO THE WEBSITE AT THIS VERY
MOMENT SO YOU GAVE ME THAT YOU
GAVE US THE- THE COSTS FOR
MODULAR HOUSING. BUT CAN YOU
GIVE US A LITTLE BIT OF THE
BREAKDOWN BETWEEN A LOW END
MOTEL VERSUS A HIGH END HOTEL
WHAT IS THE AVERAGE. COST OF
REHABILITATION IF NEEDED. BUT
THERE'S NOT REALLY A AVERAGE
COST THAT WE CAN SAY THAT. THAT
WOULD BE A FAIR ANSWER FOR YOU
BECAUSE THE- THE VERY SO WILDLY.
IT WHAT IF NEED NEED NEED YOUR
PERSONAL RIGHT. I'M THERE ARE
SEVERAL PROPERTIES THAT WERE
OFFICIALLY MOVING RIGHT. YOU
KNOW SEEN DIEGO PURCHASED
ESSENTIALLY YOU KNOW RESIDENTIAL
HOTELS REQUIRED NO
REHABILITATION. AND SO THE
ACQUISITION COSTS WITH LOCAL
HIGH. ARE THERE ARE OTHER HOTELS
MOTELS THAT REQUIRED SOME
REHABILITATION. COSTS AND SO-
WHILE WE ARE WE ARE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SOME OF THAT RESOURCE TO
DO IT IS WITH OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PARTNERS. THAT IS-ESSENTIALLY DONE OVER TALKING
ARE IN SOME CASES IT CAN GET IN
THERE AND THE REHABILITATION
COSTS CAN BE MORE THAT'S
DEFINITELY TRUE. OF THE CROSS
THE BORDER THAT'S WHAT I WAS
TRYING TO ANSWER QUESTIONS IN A
IN A FAIR WAY IT IS MUCH LESS
THE NEW CONSTRUCTION WILL COUNT
ACCOUNTABLE TO CAP OFF WITH THIS
ACQUISITION COSTS AND.
REHABILITATION KERR- I'M HAPPY I
MEAN TO RECORD ACROSS BOARD THE
AVERAGE ABOUT TO HUNDRED PER
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND. FOR UNIT.
BUT AGAIN LIKE I SAID THAT WILL
BURY PER PROP. ABOUT YEAH SUCH
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THE PER UNIT
IS THE A LOOK LIKE A LOW ONE
MULTI. OR IS THAT A HIGH END
HOTEL. BASS I'M JUST GOING BY
BASED ON YOUR STATE THE AVERAGE
COST ACROSS ACROSS THE PROGRAM
WHAT THE **** NO MATTER WHAT
THEY USE. THANK YOU AND JUST AS
A FOLLOW UP QUESTION WHAT IS THE
PERCENTAGE OF THE WORK BEING
DONE AND REHABILITATION THAT
INCLUDES UNION LABOR. AND
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS. TO GET
BACK TO YOU ON THAT IT IS- IT IS
A REQUIREMENT OF COURSE THE
PEOPLE UTILIZING THE PEOPLE
EXEMPTION WITHIN HOME HE TO DO
THAT- BUT I'D HAVE TO GET BACK
TO YOU ON THE SPECIFICS OF
PERCENTAGES. THAT WOULD BE GREAT
TANK YOU MUCH APPRECIATED AND I
WILL DO THAT BUT WE'RE NOT THE
ENTITY THAT TRACKS THAT'S THE
CORPORATE INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS
THAT IS THE OVERSIGHT ENTITY.
FOR THOSE SO THAT'S WHY. WE.
WORK WITH OUR STATE PARTNERS.
THANK YOU THAT'S UP TO THE VERY
HIGH. TO UNDER. SO I ASSUME OR
IS IT. APPROPRIATE TO ASSUME
THAT THAT DATA IS BEING SHARED.
I'D HAVE TO ASK OUR COLLEAGUES
AT THE PROBATIVE INDUSTRIALIST
INSTEAD THEY WERE ASKED IN THE
SECOND ROUND THANK YOU TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. ARE AS BIG AS
THE REGULAR HERE TO THOSE
OBLIGATIONS I DON'T KNOW YOU
KNOW. GET HOW THEY HAVE THAT
DATA BUT I'M HAPPY TO THE WE'RE
HAPPY TO HELP TRY TO MAKE THOSE
CONNECTIONS. OKAY THANK YOU MISS
WHAT'S- YES SIR THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR SO I HAD A- COUPLE
QUESTIONS FOR ALEJO- HOW MUCH DO
WE NEED TO SPEND DOWN TO AVOID
AGAIN LIMITS. ARE AND WHAT'S THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SPENDING IT ON. I THINK YOU AND I AM NOT OUR
OFFICES CAN EXPECT I'M HAPPY TO
CONNECT YOU TO THE RIGHT BOOK
CAN GET YOU AN ANSWER ON THE
MATTER I DON'T KNOW IF OUR
FINANCE COLLEAGUES HAVE ANYMORE
INSIDE ON THE SPECIFICS OF THAT.
THE JAZZ. CHRIS COOK WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I AS WELL
NOT THE SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT IN
THAT FIELD- I CAN GET BACK TO
YOU BUT ONE THING I WOULD NOTE
IS THIS TYPICALLY- FUNDING FOR
HOUSING INFRASTRUCTURE. I WOULD
NOT COUNT TOWARDS THAT GAMBLIT.
OKAY GREAT I'D BE HAPPY TO
CONNECT WITH WITH YOU ALL ABOUT
SOME OF THOSE QUESTIONS. WE DO
HAVE AN LA A COLLEAGUE WITH MORE
EXPERTISE IF YOU'D LIKE TO SORT
OF CONNECT ON HOLLINGS HAD THAT
BE GREAT IF ON. AND YEAH THANK
YOU- AND- I CAN ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION AS SORT OF A BIT
BROADLY. BECAUSE IT DEPENDS ON A
LOT OF MOVING FACTORS
UNFORTUNATELY THEY- THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT IS VERY
COMPLICATED AND- IT SORT OF
DEPENDS ON YOU KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH REVENUES ARE
HAVING A SPECIAL FUNDS IT'S ON
TRACK- BUT PROBABLY WHAT I CAN
SAY IS. THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES- I BELIEVE IT'S
ABOUT TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
WHAT WE WOULD CONSIDER AMOUNTS
THAT ARE NECESSARY IN ORDER TO
MEET THE SAU REQUIREMENTS AND SO
THIS IS- SPENDING ON CAPITAL
OUTLAY FOR EXAMPLE ADDITIONAL
SPENDING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS-
AND THOSE ARE THE AMOUNTS THAT
WOULD REALLY NEED TO BE RE
PURPOSED FOR OTHER TYPES OF CELL
EXCLUSIONS- IF. IF THE
LEGISLATURE WERE SORT OF
RECONSIDERING. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MUST WAKE SENT JUST AS A
FOLLOW UP I'M I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE CONTINUE TO
ALLOCATE FUNDING FOR HOUSING AND
CLEARLY IT IS THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE THAT WE'RE FACING
ACROSS THE STATE ORIGINALLY
THERE WAS CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
CONSTRUCTIONS FOR A CONSTRUCTION
FOR THREE POINT FIVE- MILLION
NEW HOMES BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
WHICH IS JUST AROUND THE CORNER
AND NOW- THAT'S CHANGED TO TWO
POINT FIVE BY TWENTY THIRTY.
WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
AND A WIRE IS IT BECAUSE WE ARE
SEEN. LAST NEED OR IS IT LIKE
WHAT IS THE WHAT IS THE
CHALLENGE IN ADDRESSING. THE
ORIGINAL NUMBER OF THREE POINT
FIVE VERSES THE NEW NUMBER OF
TWO POINT FIVE AND EXTENDING IT
FROM TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO
TWENTY THIRTY. THREE POINT FIVE
NUMBER WAS NOT- NEED TO THE
REPORT. AND ANALYSIS HELLO I
WILL SPEAK TO THEIR METHODOLOGY
THERE BUT I WILL STATE THAT
NUMBER IN OUR STATE WHAT HOUSING
PLAN. IS A REAL ACTIONABLE
NUMBER IT IS IT IS BECAUSE
COOLEY TOTAL IN TALLY OF WHAT
EVERY DIRECTION PERHAPS DUE PLAN
FOR UNDER THE REGIONAL HOUSING
NEEDS ALLOCATION PROCESS. SO IT
IS THE ACTUAL REAL LIKE WORKABLE
WE CAN HOLD OURSELVES
ACCOUNTABLE TO THAT NUMBER
THROUGH THE HOUSING ELEMENT PASS
AND ARE FORTUNATE IN OVERSIGHT
OF THE- BERMAN OF COURSE YOU
NEED. FOR FUNDING IN OTHER LAWS
LET'S PASSED MANY LONGER OVER
YOU TO HELP FACILITATE ARE
GREATER POWER. BUT THIS IS A NOT
A HERO NUMBER THIS IS NOT A
PACKET NUMBER THIS IS A REAL
CHANCE. ALL IN THE REQUIREMENT
AND STATUTE. WE'RE A THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION NUMBER WAS NOT A
REQUIRED. NUMBER ITS STATUTE
BECAUSE IT IS TIED TO THE MARINA
. REQUIREMENTS IT IS AN ACTION.
REAL TANGIBLE HOUSING BUBBLE
COMMITTEES MUST PLAN FOR AN WITH
. I YOU AN NSF UP WHAT IS THE
EXPECTED NUMBER OF UNITS TO BE
BUILT WITH THIS ROUND OF FUNDING. I DON'T BELIEVE WE'RE ON THE
BUDGET. ITEM FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL LIKE NEED TO STILL TRY
TO. ANSWER THAT QUESTION. I KNOW
WE'RE STILL IN THE- OKAY I JUST
IT MADE SENSE THAT I'M HAPPY I'M
HAPPY I'M HAPPY TO DO THAT BUT I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE-
GET INTO. THE WATER OKAY NO
THAT'S THAT'S A FAIR POINT
MISTRAL STAYED HOME STATE OF MY
APOLOGIES- OKAY WELL LET'S LET'S
SET UP. HASSEL LET'S PARK THAT
QUESTION FOR WHEN WE GET TO THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL BUT IT IS
SOMETHING OF INTEREST. IF THERE
ARE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
NORMENT HERE LET'S MOVE ON THEN
TO- ISSUE HOLD ON A SECOND.
ISSUE NUMBER THREE- WHICH IS THE
GOVERNOR'S HOUSINGS HOUSING
PROPOSALS. I THINK YOU'RE ON
AGAIN MYSTERONS THEATER SHOULD
WE BEGIN WITH MISS MORALES. I
THINK IT'S NAY LUCKILY I'LL LOOK
AT THAT AND IF YOU DECIDE YOU
KNOW IF THE FIRST. PLEASE
COMPLETE CONTINUE. YES HAPPY TO
DO THAT SO- WHAT YOU SEE IN THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSAL- THAT
REFLECTED JANUARY BUDGET VOCAL
AND THE RELATED BCPS HERE- ARE A
NUMBER OF INVESTMENTS AND THEY
SEEK TO BUILD ON- USING A
QUALITY IF YOU COULD BUILD ON
THE VALUES THAT I ARTICULATED
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE- AND SO
THEY FOCUS ON A COUPLE THINGS
THE COMPANY FOCUSED ON
PRODUCTION CONTINUED PRODUCTION.
ARE THERE'S ALSO AN IMPORTANT-
IN FUSION OF PROPOSALS AROUND
PRESERVATION AND PROTECTION AS
WELL OF OUR PORTAL HEALTH. SO ON
PRODUCTION- TRYING TO ACHIEVE
THE CO BENEFIT OF PRODUCING
HOUSING BUT ALSO DOING SO IN
WAYS THAT CAN HELP US REDUCE THE
EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE. AND
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION MORE BEING SUGGESTED
TALKING PERCEPTOR GRANT
PROGRAMS. OUGHT TO FOCUS ON
HELPING GET THOSE PARCELS READY
BROWNFIELD WORLD URBAN. AND
RURAL. IT COULD BE BENEFICIAL TO
COULD BE THAT THE PREPARATION OF
THE INFRASTRUCTURE FORCED TO
SUPPORT AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON
THE PARCELS- AND WITH AN
EXTENSION YOU KNOW THE EXTENSION
WAITING THE DESIRE FOR THE NEW
VEHICLE USE AND THEREFORE LOWER
GHG EMISSIONS- YOU ALSO GET A
THREE HUNDRED MILLION PROPOSED
REFORM HOUSING FOR SINGLE NEED
PROGRAM. THAT HE ADMINISTERED ON
BEHALF OF. THE ALSO WHICH IS THE
ORDER PROGRAM THAT SEEKS TO
ALIGN INVESTMENTS- WITH THE CALL
IT'S A PRETTY MORE AFFORDABLE.
HOUSING YOU ALSO SEE OUR MILLION
. TO FIND WORK. TO CONVERT
COMMERCIAL. INTO HOUSING. YOU
CAN. IT IN A HUNDRED NO DOLLARS
TO. HELP OUR EFFORTS BUILD
NUCLEAR AND LAN CONSIDER YOU
SPEAK ACCESSIBLE. SO THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE PER. ARE FOR OUR OWN
PROTECTION IN EACH YEAR BUT IT
YOU ALSO SEE ANOTHER FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION. THE STATE.
LOCAL TAX CREDIT WORTH AND THE
PERPETRATORS. AND YOU BILLION
FOR THE FOR MAKING HEALTH
PRODUCTION. AND BY THE SOUTH
CALIFORNIA. STATE GETS ITS. BUT
YOU AS IMPORTANT AS I AT THE AT
THE CONTINUE. NEW CONSTRUCTION
IS THERE ARE RESOURCES FOR
RESERVE HOUSING NEVER THE FOR
TO. SO YOU SEE TWO ONE MILLION
PROPOSED TO NERVOUS- IN WHAT WE
GET OUR LOW USED. INCLUDING
ENERGY RETROFIT AND TOWARD.
HOUSING OFFERS THERE BEING THE
THAT WE ALREADY HAVE. OIL AND
OTHER VERY HE'SOUR EFFORTS TO.
EXPAND WHAT WE DO AROUND AND
THEY- HOMES- IT'S REALLY
CRITICAL. OFF ACTUALLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND THERE'S A
HUNDRED MILLION THAT WE PROPOSE
TO. EXPAND OUR WORKFORCE IN
MAKING SURE THOSE PROPERTIES
ARE- RETAINED FOR THE USES OF
COURSE AND TO MAKE CRITICAL
HEALTH AND SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS
AS NECESSARY. TO HELP THEM.
REGAIN AND SO THAT'S THE
PROPOSAL AROUND A HUNDRED
MILLION TO EXPAND OUR OLD CAR
IMPROPER PROGRAM. IT'LL END BY
MENTIONING AS THEY DID EARLIER
ON THE CALENDAR OF ALL OF OUR
EXISTING INVESTMENTS IT IS
AVAILABLE ON PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
ON ITS WEBSITE. FOR EXAMPLE ARE
CAN I OUR SECOND OF I'M GOING TO
THE HOUSING STELLARATOR ABOUT
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION JUST
RELEASED AND WE ARE ON TRACK TO
RELEASED THE SUPERNOVA. OF MEAT
MANY OF OUR PROGRAMS LOCALLY
HOUSING PROGRAM THE JUST SORT OF
PROGRAMMED STRUCTURED GRANT
PROGRAMS EXISTING DOLLARS AND
THE DIFFERENCE I THINK IT WILL
PREVENTION PROGRAM- AB.
REALIZING WHAT EIGHTY FOUR
SUGGESTED THAT SHOULD BE OUT AT
THE END OF. SO THESE ARE A LOT A
LOT OF REFER FIRST BILL OUT EVEN
AFTER MAKE PROPOSALS. ARE HAPPY
ADDRESS THE. THANK YOU LET'S
HEAR FROM THE OHIO BY POUND IF I
. IN ONE SECOND OR THIS MODEL
WHAT THE A. L. I'M OUR OFFICE
RECENTLY REAL A BUT- OUTLINED
OUR COMMENTS THE GOVERNOR. I'M
HELPING. THOSE ARE FOR BRIEFLY
SUMMARIZED IN THE PROJECT
HIGHLIGHTED PEOPLE DID POINT.
ONE IS A KNOW THE FOR SECOND
BENEFITS AND I BY THE MINUTE.
BUILDING MORE DENSELY ADDRESSING
THE STATE I'M HOW GOALS WE
SHOULD KNOW THAT IT HAS MERIT-
BUT MORTGAGE ON THAT FRONT THE
LONG TERM WILL BE FOR THE
NECESSARY TO FULLY ALIGN THE
STATE'S HOUSING. AND CLIMATE
GOALS. WE BE IN A COLLECTIVE THE
HOUSING FOR. WERE SORT OF BILL
MORE HOW ACROSS STATE PROVIDE.
YOU KNOW HOW UNITS ARE PRECISELY
WHERE IT'S THAT YOU KNOW IT'S
NOT COMPLETELY CLEAR AT THIS
POINT. AND SO HE GET MISTER.
FULLY FLESHED OUT STAND HOW DOES
THE WORK WILL BE GIVEN BE
IMPORTANT. ANOTHER ELEMENT THAT
WE WOULD NOTICE- I MEAN. IT
DOESN'T ALLEGE THE DRINKING AGE
ON HOW THE COLLECTION THE
COLLECTIVE PACKAGE OF HOUSING
PROPOSAL TO ALIGN WITH RECENT
POLICY CHANGES. SO FOR EXAMPLE
ON THE LEGISLATURE HAS RECENTLY
I'M STREAMLINED THAT PROCESS FOR
APPROVING FIFTY TEXAS. YOU KNOW
ABOUT HOW OLD THIS ARMENIAN
ALIGN WITH SORT OF MEETING ITS-
BROADER POLICY GOALS. I'M COULD
BE AFFECTED AS WELL- AND WE'RE
WORKING WITH SOME. HAVE
INDICATED EARLIER TODAY IS THE
ABOUT THE STATE OF LONG TERM
EFFECTS IMPASSE. IN HOUSING- CAN
YOU ABOUT WHAT LONG TERM. ON
THAT WILL BE EMPTY AT THE WILL
LIKE HAVE A- TO FISCAL ROLE TO-
IT'S- THE LONGER TERM. THE FACT
THE FINAL QUESTION WHICH NOT
THAT. ALLOCATED FUNDING- FOR
EXPLICIT PURPOSES WOULD ALLOW.
STATE TO ALLAH MORE FOR TOWARD
HELPING TO OTHERWISE COULD BE.
THANK YOU. FINANCE CHRIS WHAT
DEPARTMENT FINING NO FURTHER
COMMENTS BUT OF HOPE QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CAN EIGHT
CITY WALK US THROUGH THE
QUESTIONS AND OF THE STAFF
COMMENTS PLACE.
SO YOU HAVE A BILL IN ORDER WILL
THAT WORK FOR YOU. THE FRST
QUESTION I SEE IS WHAT. WE
DISCUSS WHAT PROGRAMS REQUIRE
HOUSING COMPLIANCE IS THOSE ARE
THE QUESTIONS. WE CAN GO BY
ORDER THANK YOU SIR I'M STILL
HOUSING ELEMENT COMPLIANCE IS
REQUIRED BY STATUTE. OR FUNDING
DISBURSED TO LOCALITIES THROUGH
THE SB TWO REVENUE. ARE WHAT WE
CALL THE PERMANENT LOCAL HOUSING
ALLOCATION THAT IS- IT'S GOT YOU
IT'S ALSO REQUIRED FOR THE
PORTIONS OF THE RECENT TWENTY
NINETEEN. GENERAL FUND
ALLOCATION STUDENTS ALL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM-
IT'S REQUIRED FOR THE LOCAL
HOUSING TRUST FUND PROGRAM.
PORTABLE HEALTH INSISTING.
PROGRAM IT IS REQUIRED SB
CALTRAIN THE STATE. FRANCE AND
IT IS REQUIRED FOR HOME GRANTS
THAT ARE FEDERAL SOURCES THAT
ARE AWARDED TO YOU- NOT A TITLE
JURISDICTION EACH YOU GET
MINISTERS- WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
A LOCAL HOUSING TRUST FUND
PROGRAM. ALL OF THOSE REQUIRE
HOUSING ON THE COMPLAINTS AT THE
TIME OF THE AWARD. SHOW- THAT
WOULD LOOK UP THE TRUST FUND IS
THE ONLY PROGRAM THAT REQUIRES
IT TO BE COMPLIANT THE TIME OF
THE APPLICATIONS. MIDDLE EAST.
ANY QUESTIONS ON THAT WOULD LOOK
IN THE BOX AND- NO I GUESS I
EIGHT THANK YOU FOR THAT I
APPRECIATE IT- CAN WE GO BACK TO
MY ORIGINAL QUESTION- THAT I HAD
ASKED IN THE PREVIOUS PANEL SO
WITH THIS THIS HOUSING FUNDING
INVESTMENT HOW MANY UNITS ARE
ANTICIPATED. LET ME LET ME GET
THOSE NUMBERS TALLIED I HAVE
BEEN BY PROGRAM AND SINCE I'M
KIND OF STILL TALKING TO YOU I'M
GONNA NEED SOMEONE TO SEND ME
THOSE NUMBERS ALL HAVE BEEN WITH
YOU WITHIN MINUTES- BECAUSE WE
KIND OF A TALIBAN. ECT SO- ON
THE OVERALL NUMBER I IF SOMEONE
COULD THERE ARE CHRIS I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU CAN IF YOU CAN FIND
OUT FROM HER. OUR ALL HAPPY
PROVIDE THAT THE AND- THAT'S
WHAT. WHAT ABOUT PROGRAMS THAT
WE HAVE ALREADY FOR TO AVE THE
NUMBERS READILY AVAILABLE.
FOSTER WHAT PROGRAM I MEAN HAPPY
TO ANSWER WHAT PROGRAM WOULD YOU
LIKE TO HEAR ABOUT. MAYBE MAYBE
THAT'S WHAT WOULD BE HELPFUL I
KNOW THAT YOU HAD. EXPRESSED
QUITE A BIT OF INTEREST IN HOW
MANY UNITS WERE ACTUALLY BUILT.
UP WITH A CONSTRUCTION OFFER OUR
BIGGEST KIND OF PROGRAMS LOCALLY
HOUSING PROGRAM YEAH I G.
PROGRAM AGENCY WHICH WE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT OTHER VETERANS
HOUSING ON THE PREVENTION
PROGRAM THE DISCERNING PROGRAM.
ALL TOLD- IN THE LAST SEVERAL
FUNDING CYCLE TO PRODUCE FORTY
ONE THOUSAND FUNDED UNITS-
COMPLETE AND CONSTRUCTED ARE A
LITTLE OVER FORTY FOUR THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED UNITS THERE ARE
QUITE A FEW- UNITS IN
CONSTRUCTION IN FACT I WOULD SAY
RIGHT AT THE PRECIPICE OF
REALIZING- ALL THE BENEFITS THAT
WE WANTED TO SEE. FROM ALL THE
BENEFITS OF THE LAST YOUR PROP
ONE- AND OTHER RELATED FUNDING
SO WE HAVE OVER THIRTEEN
THOUSAND UNITS INFRASTRUCTURE
RIGHT NOW ABOUT TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND THAT ARE AWARDED TO GET
TO BE IN CONSTRUCTION BUT I
WOULD ADD THAT WE EXPECT MANY OF
THOSE TO BE IN CONSTRUCTION THIS
YEAR. ESPECIALLY GIVEN HOW THE
ACCELERATOR FUNDING ON
ESPECIALLY THE- ENABLING WHEN
YOU TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
TRADITIONAL. FINANCES TAX A BOMB
AND MANY OTHERS OF COURSE THOSE
WELL IT WILL ONE ZERO. THAT
PIECE OF MY WHETHER THE
EXTERNAL. OR THE FACT ABOUT
AFTER BIRTH BROWN WITH. EIGHTY
DAYS SO WE'RE RIGHT ON REST OF
THE BEING QUITE YOU- NOTHING
GETS BUILT ON THE- LIKE I SAID.
CURRENTLY OVER THIRTEEN IN.
EXPECT MORE. COMING YEAR FOR
EXAMPLE IF. ALL THOSE PROJECTS
THAT WE JUST BUDGET IN THE FIRST
YEAR AFTER BIRTH. I THOUGHT WE
WOULD EXPECT THAT WOULD HAPPEN
THAT'S ANOTHER TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED UNITS- OBVIOUSLY HOKEY
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS AN OVER THE
COUNTER- BASIS AND YOU HAVE. ALL
THOSE CAPITAL EXPENDITURES IT'S
BEEN A DIRT BIKE THAT YOU HAVE
TO BE- ACTUALLY MADE WITHIN
EIGHT MONTHS OF A WORK. AND SO
WE SEE AN ALREADY WORKING FOR
FIRST ROUND QUITE A FEW ALTHOUGH
ALMOST ALL OF UNITS COMING
ONLINE IN THE FIRST ROUND. AND
WILL CONTINUE TO BE THAT
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR MAR
REFERENCE AS WE MAKE THE OVER
THE COUNTER FOR HOPING TO FOR
HELP AND BEYONCE- AND LIKE I
SAID WE CONTINUE TO RELEASE
FUNDING FOR A LOT OF THESE
PROGRAMS SO THE NUMBERS ARE
FLUID AND CHANGING AS WE MAKE
THE WORK OF COURSE. WE ARE
SEEING QUITE A BIT FOR THAT
EIGHT BILLION I TALKED ABOUT THE
FORTY ONE THOUSAND UNITS THAT
WE'VE TALKED WE'VE INVESTED IN-
TO. TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE THOSE COME
ONLINE AND. IN FACT MOST OF THEM
ARE INFRASTRUCTURE. YEAH BUT
THE- QUESTION HALF TO A LAB. I
KNOW PROVIDED YOUR BUT STAFF
WITH. A LIKE A DOCTOR. TRYING TO
. ON PRO. WILL BACK PRIOR TO
TESTIFY IN THE SENATE. SO THAT
MADE IT WHEN YOU- BUT HAPPY TO A
LAB. ON THAT DOCTOR. OR. FOR
THANK YOU AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
THIS IS A LOT OF AND- L. OF.
DOLLARS GOING INTO ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE STATE'S BIGGEST
CONCERN WHEN IT COMES TO
HOUSING. AND SO WHAT I'M- I
THINK WE WERE ALL TRYING TO GET
AT IS MEASUREMENTS OF SUCCESS.
AND SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT PROJECTS
THAT HAVE BEEN FUNDED IN THE
PAST WHAT WORKS WHAT DOESN'T CAN
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY GETTING THAT
REPORT WOULD BE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT. YOU ALSO MENTIONED
THAT MHP CREATES A LOT OF
HOUSING. BUT THE GOVERNOR'S-
PACKAGE DOESN'T INCLUDE FUNDING
FOR MHP AND- CURIOUS AS TO WHY
THAT IS. WELL WE STILL HAVE TO
MAKE FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR PROP
ONE. WE WILL HAVE A LOT OF
RELEASED IT'S PART OF OUR SUPER
NO BUT THEY'LL BE OUT THERE THIS
MONTH AND THEN WILL BE ANOTHER
ROUND OF FUNDING IN THE FALL
IT'S- NOT THE FOLLOWING YEAR- SO
THERE IS STILL RESOURCES FROM
HP. LIKE I SAID MORE WORK OUR
JOB IS TO DEPLOY THOSE FUNDS- I
LEAVE IT TO YOU GUYS THE CRAFT
HOW HOW WHAT YOU THINK THE
APPROPRIATE INVESTMENTS MIGHT
EAT- I WILL SAY THE PROPOSED
INVESTMENT. IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THANK YOU FOR INDULGING
OF BEING PATIENT WITH ME. HELLO
TALLY THE NUMBER IS AROUND
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND UNITS- THAT
WOULD BE AT THE STATE OP FIVE BY
THE ABOUT THE PROPOSED THAT I
LAID OUT THERE- BUT. I'M HAPPY
TO- YOUR LAB RIGHT WHAT THOSE
PRO IS GIVING TERMS OF WHAT THE-
THAT THE STEP. YEAH WE WANT THAT
YOU BUILT. UNIT THAT IS BILL.
THROUGH THE HOUSEHOLD ALLOWING
HELP COUNCIL. AND DOUBLE. OF I
HAVE. IN MY- ALL CASES. MANY
HOUSEHOLD OVER THE LIFE OF THE
HOUSING BECAUSE WE STAFF FOR
REQUIRED THAT UNITS TO BE
AFFORDABLE FOR FIFTY FIVE YEARS
. OTHER THEN YOU ADD IN THINGS
LIKE HOME HE OF THE XCELERATED
DOES IT MAKE THOSE ARE THOSE
LOOKING AT A MUCH FASTER RATE
EVERY EVERY HOPE UNIT. RAIDED
THE HOME OF HOUSEHOLD OFF THE
STREET. ND SO THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE METRICS I WOULD DEFINITELY.
CONSIDER WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO
GO AS IF THEY WERE HOUSING PLAN
IT KNOWLEDGE. WE HAVE UNDER
INVESTED IN UNDER PRODUCED IN
HOUSING FOR MANY DECADES AND SO-
WE NEED TO BUILD THESE UNITS OF
PASSAGE YOU CAN'T YOU SEE. KIND
OF MORE UNIQUE PROGRAMS LIKE
HOKEY AND ACCELERATOR KIND OF
CIRCUMVENT WHAT IS THAT
TRADITIONAL FUNDING PROCESS THAT
CAN TAKE A COUPLE YEARS. OF A
WEALTH OF. THE PEAK FOR TAX
CREDITS AND- FACT THE FUNDS- ONE
OF THE REASONS WE- ACCELERATE
FOR. WHAT PURPOSE FOR EXAMPLE IF
WE HAD A LOT OF PROJECTS READY
TO GO THAT ROUTE IF WAITING
THEIR TURN. AND WE WERE OF THE-
SYSTEM DID NOT CONTEMPLATE.
COMPETITION AND HAD TO ADJUST
YOUR LAST TWO YEARS. WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING. WITH OUR PARTNERS
IN THE RECORDS OFFICE YOU'RE- UP
EIGHT THE- PROGRAMS TO
OFFICIALLY ALLOW FOR COMPETITION
THAT BETTER REFLECTS. HOW THESE
PRODUCTS CAN COMPETE. IN THE
MEANTIME WHERE WE CAME IN WITH
THE EXCEL WORD- FUNDING TO HELP
WITH THOSE PROJECTS ALONG SO-
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A HOPE THAT-
ARE STATE FUNDED THAT'S WITH.
TV'S AND- WILL WILL COMPETE
FAVORABLY IN THAT AND FACT THAT
IT. AND ABU SYSTEM. BUT WE ARE
FOR OR WHAT DOES THIS CAN PER
THAT WHY YOU ALSO THE AMOUNT. OF
IS THAT CIRCUMVENT THAT MICHAEL.
EXCEL YOU OFF SEE A NEED FOR
PRESERVE WHAT WE ARE HAVE A- IT
IS LOOKS FOR US TO. BOB
HERTZBERG SOMETHING ALREADY IN
OUR PARKING LOT OR THAN TO GET
TO BE. THANK YOU I A- THE CAR TO
BE HONEST I THINK WE'RE ALL IN
AGREEMENT OF TRYING TO REACH.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL OF TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION- HOUSING
UNITS WITHIN BY TWENTY THIRTY
WHICH IS JUST EIGHT YEARS AWAY
SO. IF THE PROPOSAL NOW IS
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND. ANNUALLY
OR EVERY TO EVERY TWO YEARS MY
APOLOGIES THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND
EVERY TWO YEARS. HOW DOES THAT
GET US TO THE TWO POINT FIVE.
WELL THE THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND
THAT WOULD BE GREAT WOULD BE
WHAT THE GOVERNOR PROPOSING THIS
REMEMBER WE HAVE SIX POINT FIVE
BILLION ON TOP OF THAT ARE YOU
JUST GOING AT THIS YEAR. WE ARE
STILL SEEING THE REALIZATION OF
COURSE OF THE INVESTMENTS MADE
IN THE PREVIOUS RECORDING THOSE
ARE JUST NOW GETTING
CONSTRUCTING COME ALIVE. I ALSO
OF COURSE MENTIONED THERE THE
STATE IS NOT THE ONLY THUNDER.
UP LOCAL HAVE RESOURCES THEY
CONTROL ARE OFTEN THOSE ARE
FEDERAL RESOURCES THE FLOW
DIRECTLY FOR LARGE AND WITH
THEIR DIFFERENT. OUT THERE ARE
FEDERAL FUNDS THAT WE YOU KNOW
IT'S JUST A FAKE CERTAINLY- AND
IF YOU TO FLOW. AND SO THERE ARE
MANY KINDS THERE ARE MANY OR
MANY PARTS TO THE SOLUTION IT'S
NOT JUST THE STATE'S OR ENTITIES
FUNDED SOLUTIONS. THAT'S WHY I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE NEED THE
PARTNERSHIP. AT EVERY LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT AND WITH OUR PRIVATE
SECTOR PARTNERS RIGHT- THERE ARE
RESOURCES IN ADDITION TO WHAT.
THE STATE PROVIDES TO HELP BUT
YOU. THANK YOU I. TRUST ME WHEN
I TELL YOU THAT WE HAVE A LOT
MORE QUESTIONS I'M GONNA. ASK MY
COLLEAGUE MS MS WAKES UP A
COUPLE OF HERSELF THANK YOU. AND
THANK YOU AND SERVE I MISSED
THIS BUT JUST SPECIFICALLY WHICH
PROGRAMS ARE PRODUCING THE MOST
HOUSING. THE GREAT QUESTION- I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S THE RIGHT ONE
BECAUSE I THINK IT WOULD IT
WOULD BE AT SOME PROGRAM TO
PRODUCE THE MOST BECAUSE THEY-
HAVE THE MOST MONEY ALLOCATED.
RIGHT SO YOU KNOW WE SEE IT WE
SEE SOMETHING THAT ACTUAL SPEED
URGENCY. AT HOME KEY THANKS AT A
LOWER PRICE POINT IN PREGNANCY
THAT'S ONLINE MUCH QUICKER. THAN
THAT IS AN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION. HE WE GET A LOT
OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS WE HAVE
PASSED THE STATE HOUSING BONDS
WITH RECENT ONE BEING PROP ONE
AT THE END OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
SO YOU SEE THOSE AMOUNTS TO BURY
I WOULD SAY THE MOST THE MOST
SOUGHT AFTER PROGRAM AND HE KIND
OF LIKE FOUNDATIONAL PROGRAM IS
THE MULTI FAMILY HOUSING PROGRAM
. BUT IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT YOU.
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT MANY OF THE
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT WE
ADMINISTER HEALTH MINISTER YOU
HAVE TARGETED GOALS TO THEM AS
WELL. SO YOU THINK ABOUT
SOMETHING LIKE THE NETFLIX
ACCOUNT PROGRAM THE VETERANS
HOUSING HOPE BETTER PROGRAM OR
THE FOR THE HEALTHY SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM. SOMETIMES
THOSE MAY PRODUCE FEWER UNITS.
THEY ARE SPEAKING HAVE A BENEFIT
OF DOING SOMETHING LIKE ENDING
HOME. OR THE COUNCIL OR- IF YOU
CAN TO OUR CLIMATE WILL AND SO
I'M THERE ARE DIFFERENT TRADE
OFFS OF COURSE WHEN YOU TRY TO
MEET LOCAL. I AM. AND POLITICAL
THE HOUSING FOR IS THE MOST KIND
OF DIRECT. IT'S AFFORDABLE FOR
LOCAL SCHOOLS. AND JUST UP ON
THAT- THANK YOU BRING THAT UP
HOW TOTALS LEFT TO GO OUT. IN AN
H. P. AND WHAT WE DO IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE SINCE. WILL AWARD
AT ALL BY THE END OF NEXT YEAR.
BUT STILL WILL TWENTY TWENTY
THREE THERE WILL BE ADDITIONAL
NOBLE WITH IMAGE IN IT. EIGHTY
FOUR THIRTY FOUR SUPPORT FOR
WILL HAVE ONE THIS. MONTH WILL
HAVE ANOTHER NEXT YEAR. ABOUT I
THINK TWO HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION LEFT IN A
MEETING. SO THAT WOULD BE GOING
OUT FOR APPLICATIONS NEXT.
SPRING TWENTY TWENTY THREE IT
WOULD MAKE THOSE AWARDS LEAVING
TWENTY TWENTY. AFTER WHICH WE
WOULD. ACTUALLY WITH. SORRY
AFTER WHICH WOULD YOU WOULD YOU
THE MORE. AFTER TWENTY. WE HAVE
A THE NEXT WE HAVE A NO BUT THIS
WILL WORK FOR IT AND AN OPEN
NEXT MARCH FOR. GOT IT OKAY. AND
THEN THE AWARDS OF CORPORATE
FOLLOW MID YEAR PROBABLY MID
LATE YEAR THE FINAL SEMESTER
MHPS NOW WE'RE WE'RE NOT
REQUIRED TO CONSOLIDATE OUR
PROGRAMS DO WITH THEM THEIR
DELETE EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY FOUR
AND THAT INCLUDES THE MULTIPLE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BEFORE WE
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
WE'RE GOING TO DO ROLL CALL
AGAIN FOR OUR VOTE ONLY- ITEMS
WHICH ARE ITEMS ONE AND THEN
THREE TO SEVEN. THE MOTION WAS
THE I'M SORRY ROLL CALL PLEASE
FOR THE MEMBERS ARE ABSENT. AT
THE RECOMMENDATION OF THE
PREVIOUS BUDGET COOPER HI THIS
AREA. THE HI A MOTION TO AND-
VOTE ONLY ISSUE NUMBER TWO
PLEASE COOPER HI THIS AREA HI.
THANK YOU GENTLEMEN WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR. MR
ON STATE YOU'RE STILL ON THE HOT
SEAT. THANK YOU- OKAY SO- ON ON
NUMBER FOUR IF YOU SEE HERE IS A
RECOMMENDATION THAT WEEKEND RE
OF ALLAH DOES THAT COMMITTEE OFF. SO WE'RE LOOKING TO RE
APPROPRIATE AROUND TWENTY TWO
MILLION FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND UP WITH PURPOSE.
FOR THE HOUSING SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY PROGRAM SO A WORK MADE
WAY BACK WHEN THAT PROGRAM WAS
CREATED TWENTY FOURTEEN. THEY
HAVE AN E. COMMERCE DEADLINE.
AND THERE ARE A COUPLE PROJECTS
THAT HAVE BEEN SOLD FOR VARIOUS
REASONS READ REASONS- YOU KNOW
NOT A NOT NOT AMONG THEM OF
COURSE ALL THE THINGS WE HAVE WE
CAN TALK ABOUT BUT- YOU KNOW THE
PANDEMIC AND OTHER THINGS. I'M
THAT IT. OUR TECH POTENTIALLY IN
JEOPARDY OF MEETING THE DEADLINE
AND IF. IF THERE'S NOT A
ADJUSTMENTS THE PROJECT WILL
HAPPEN IN THE FUNDS WERE BACK
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND ASSISTING BEING THEY WILL
YOU FOR HOUSE. SO OUR- GUESTS
AND IS THAT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE. THOSE DOLLARS SO
THAT I CAN. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I'M SORRY- ELLIE- FIRST. ALLEY NO ISSUES TO RAISE WITH
THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. CHRIS
CROOK DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS BUT HELPFUL
QUESTIONS. OKAY I WOULD JUST
ASK- MR ALMOST AND IF YOU COULD
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS AND
QUESTIONS- PRESENTED BY STAFF.
OUR STAFF COMMENTS I SHOULD SAY
. YOU COULD TELL ME THE PROMISE
THAT WOULD BE GREAT I DO NOT
HAVE THE ABILITY WITH BEING A
CAMPER AND EVERYTHING TO MULTI
TASK AB ALL THE- ALL THE
DOCUMENTS. COULD YOU PLEASE. LET
ME KNOW WHAT THE QUESTIONS ARE.
AND I MAY BE ABLE TO PASS ITS MY
COLLEAGUES WERE AVAILABLE. I
THINK. SO SHORT ON THE AGENDA
PAGE TWENTY NINE SO THAT WE'RE
ALL ON THE SAME PAGE UNDER STAFF
COMMENTS HAS REQUESTED
INFORMATION ON THE- ON THE EIGHT
PROJECTS CURRENTLY UNDER
CONSTRUCTION AND WHEN IT IS.
WHEN IT IS ANTICIPATED THAT THE
EIGHT PROJECTS WILL BE COMPLETE
. WHY IS IT TAKING SO LONG TO
COMPLETE THESE PROJECTS. YES I
KNOW THAT- I KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
FUND YOUR WALLET THE DELAYS I
JUST TODAY. LEAVE IT NOW ONLY
TWO PROJECTS THAT ARE IN
JEOPARDY. I I'M HAPPY TO- YEAH.
I GUESS WE'RE GONNA SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THESE PROJECTS RIGHT
SO DOES THE THERE'S A LOT OF
REASONS WHY PRODUCT MAKE IT
RIGHT- AMONG THEM SPEAKING OTHER
FINAL RESOURCES- AFTER TWO YEARS
IF YOU MAY KNOW THERE'S BEEN A
SEVERE OVER SUBSCRIPTION EVERY
PROGRAM UP UNTIL THE ACCELERATOR
HOME HE EVERY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROGRAM WITH MR. WELL I DON'T
SEE A LOT ABOUT THE TAX RATES OR
TAX EXEMPT BONDS ONE OF THESE
THEIR CLIENTS. THAT THE MODEL
BEFORE BEFORE BUT THE FINANCE
FOR A COUPLE DECADES NOW AND SO
OFTEN AND WE SAW A VERY VASTLY
OVERSUBSCRIBED ENVIRONMENT THERE
OF THE LAST COUPLE YEARS. THAT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY WE
PROPOSE THE EXCAVATOR PROGRAM IS
TAKING MANY ITERATIONS WITHIN
THE PROJECT. AS ONE OF THE
REASONS FOR. ARE OFTEN THERE CAN
BE OTHER OTHER. OTHER OTHER
REASONS KNOW MANY. OF COURSE
HAVE NOT ASPECTS THAT IS JUST
ABOUT BUT OF THE TAX CREDIT AND
- THAT LIMON ALLOCATION
COMMITTEES. OR EXTENSIONS DURING
THE AND- SO- YEAH THESE ARE
THERE TWO NOW THAT LOOK LIKE
THEY'RE POTENTIALLY IN JEOPARDY.
OF ABOUT FOUR POINT EIGHT
MILLION IN DEMAND- AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO RETAIN
THESE DOLLARS WITH THIS. ASK FOR
HOUSING PURPOSES OTHERWISE THOSE
PROJECTS WOULD. POTENTIALLY NOT
HAPPENED- AND WE KNOW THAT IT'S
SO IMPORTANT THAT WE CAN GET
EVERY PROJECT THAT CAN BE BUILT
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE. AND SO-
YOU KNOW THERE ARE ALSO.
SOMETHING TO THINK ABOUT WHAT IN
THE WORLD. WE NEED PROGRAM IS
THAT HAVE A TRANSIT OKAY. SO I
BELIEVE THAT ONE OF THE PROJECTS
THERE HAS PAUL HAS. SUPPOSEDLY
NOT ON. HOUSING PIECE BUT ON THE
TRANSIT HE'S- I. SO THEY HAVE DO
TRANSIT IMPROVEMENTS WILL
INCLUDE. SINCE OF A FUNDING SOME
ROADBLOCKS IT'S- OUR OTHER H. H.
AS THE ALLOCATIONS HAVING THE
SIMILAR ISSUES. ON THE LAST
LITTLE BIT. THIS THIS THIS WITH
DIFFICULT QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
TWENTY FOURTEEN FUNDS EVER SINCE
THAT I BELIEVE THE FUNDS WERE-
IT SHE IS THE APPROPRIATE AFTER
THAT SO WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS- I GUESS WHAT I CAN
SAY IS IN TERMS OF IN TERMS OF
THE LATE THERE CERTAINLY WERE A
NUMBER OF AGENCY FUNDED PROJECT
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO GET GOING
WITH THE ACCELERATOR FUNDS- ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WAS OCCURRING
WITHIN THE FINAL PIECE OF
FINANCING IN TAXPAYERS OFFICE
MEDIAN FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEBT
LIMIT ALLOCATION COMMITTEE WHERE
THOSE PRODUCTS ARE GOING TO SEEK
THE FINAL THE FINANCING. IS
THOSE TYPES OF PROJECTS OR
HOUSES ASSEMBLY PROJECTS TEND TO
BE MORE EXPENSIVE BECAUSE
THEY'RE THEY'RE TYPICALLY INFILL
PROJECTS THEY'RE TYPICALLY DOING
TRANSIT IMPROVEMENTS AS WELL AND
WITHIN THE METRICS. AS I
MENTIONED THE DEBT LIMIT OUT
THINKING THEY COULD NOT REALLY
CONTEMPLATE A SCORING SYSTEM
THAT WAS COMPETITIVE AND SO THE
ONLY THE ONLY WAY THE TIEBREAKER
ESSENTIALLY WAS THE COST OF THE
HOUSE ARE YOU CAN GET THE
PROMOTE EFFICIENCY SO MANY MANY
WHAT HOUSING IN THE BOOKING
THESE PROJECTS WORKED WITH ALL
THEIR- NOTHING. THEY WERE GREAT
PROUD ELECT I SAID IT'S A OF
THESE PRO THAT HAVE COME
BENEFITS OF IN FROM INFO FROM
COST. IF WE'RE GETTING THE
FINISH. IN A FIGHT IN THE VERY
COMPETITIVE SO YES THERE
ASSEMBLY THERE WE FREEDOM MOST
OF THE- WITH THE. THANK YOU CAN
YOU CAN YOU CLEAR SOMETHING YOU
MENTIONED THAT THESE PRO. ARE
MARKED. YET WE'RE PUTTING MORE
FUNDING INTO THEM AND THEY'RE
TAKING LONGER SO WHAT'S THE
RATIONALE TO THAT. WELL WE ARE
THINKING THAT THE FORT WORTH
STILL NEEDS PROGRAM AS CREATED
BY THE LEGISLATURE MANY YEARS
AGO DOES HAVE TO GO BACK A
COUPLE OF NOT ONLY CREATING
HOUSING THE CLOAKING THEIR AND
YOUR TRANSIT. LARGELY AT. THAT
COST MORE MONEY- I THINK. IT'S
THERE ARE MULTIPLE BENEFITS AND
THAT'S WHY COST. AND LIKE I SAID
DELAYS WERE A FUNCTION OF THE
HOUSING FINANCE SYSTEM. AND THE
FACT THAT CALIFORNIA DEBT LIMIT
OUT IF YOU COMMITTEE. OF WHICH
DID NOT HAVE A COMPETITIVE
SCORING STRUCTURE WHEN THEY WERE
OVERSUBSCRIBED SO THE LAST TWO
YEARS. IF YOU NEED HELP OR
NOTHING YES THEY CAN BE FORMER
FINANCE OPERATORS OFFICE THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE WHO ARE ALL
REPRESENTED ON THE COMMITTEES
HAVE BEEN. PUSHING FOR
REGULATORY CHANGES TO CHANGE THE
SUPPORT SYSTEMS TO ALLOW FOR
BETTER. A BETTER REFLECTION OF
EIGHT- A PUBLIC BENEFIT
ACHIEVING BENEFIT WITH THOSE AND
- BECAUSE WHAT WILL HAPPENING IS
THE CHEAPEST PROJECTS WITH-
GETTING FUNDED THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THEY WERE THE BEST PROJECT
NECESSARILY LIKE I SAID BEFORE
HOUSING. IN MANY PROGRAM. THE
NEW POLITICAL PROJECTS THAT SEEK
TO THIRTY FOUR HOMELESS DOES
COST MORE MONEY TYPICALLY- SO
THEY WERE OFFICIALLY STARTED
NEED. LARGELY BECAUSE THAT
THOSE- AT THE FUNDING. THANK YOU
MISS WHAT'S- THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND UP FOR JUMPING ON HER
LITTLE BIT BUT I SAID A COUPLE
OTHER FOLLOWUP QUESTIONS SO
THAT THE GOAL OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN TO
STREAMLINE MULTIPLE PROGRAMS TO
MAKE THE PROGRAMS MORE EFFICIENT
TO GET THE MONEY OUT FASTER AND
ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS AS QUICKLY
AS WE POSSIBLY CAN. THE BUDGET
PROPOSES CREATING A NEWER
ADAPTIVE REUSE PROGRAM WHICH
RUNS COUNTER TO THAT GOAL WHITE
WHY DO WE NEED A NEW PROGRAM. WE
DON'T BELIEVE IT CALPERS THE
GOAL- AT ALL IN FACT. THE FIRST
BILL LANGUAGE THAT WE'VE
SUGGESTED HERE WHAT ALLOW US TO
APPLY IT. TO ANY OF OUR PROGRAMS
SO THAT WE CAN GET THE MONEY OUT
AS QUICK AS POSSIBLE. IF SO WE
WOULD BE TYING IT TO OTHER
PROGRAMS- NOW THE REASON WHY I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT IS BECAUSE-
I'M A LITTLE BIT OF THE ESSENCE
HERE. WHEN IT COMES TO A DOCTOR
PREVIOUS. WE TALK A LITTLE BIT-
EARLIER RIGHT ABOUT. CLUNKY AND
WE REALLY ABLE WITH SWIFT ACTION
THAT THE STATE TOOK CARE TO
ACQUIRE MANY DIFFERENT ASSETS.
WERE DISTRESSED BECAUSE AND- IT
SO WE MAY BE IN THAT SIMILAR
SITUATION RIGHT NOW. WHERE THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF DISTRESSED
ASSETS AT. PRESENT YOU KNOW WE
MAY TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF EFFORT
TO ACQUIRE ORCHESTRA INTO
HOUSING. BUT YOU KNOW IN. THE
FUTURE THEY MAY NOT THEY MAY NOT
BE AVAILABLE RECKLESS CERTAINLY
ALREADY SEEN. NEED FOR THE
MINISTRY COME BACK QUITE
AGGRESSIVELY. AND YOU WERE YOUR
OF THOSE. OFFICES ARE AVAILABLE
SO THIS IS SPEAKING TO A I DID
WHAT THE- BEING OF QUICK THAT. I
THE BILL. YOU ADVANTAGE THANK
YOU SO I IT WILL BE THREE
BECAUSE WE STRUCK. YOU WILL BE
ASKED TO ALLOW US TO- THAT WITH
WITH WHATEVER PROGRAM YEP WE
HAVE THE NEXT ONE TO DO THAT
WOULD BE WITH THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SUSTAINABLE BUT THAT
WOULD COME OUT THIS FALL. THAT
WOULD BE THE FIRST OPPORTUNITY
WITHIN THE BUDGET YEAR. OKAY AND
LAST YEAR AB EIGHT SIXTEEN
REQUIRED EIGHT CD TO PRIORITIZE
FUNDING FOR THE FEDERAL HOUSING
TRUST FUND FOR DEVELOPMENTS FOR
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
IS IT TRUE THAT THE FEDERAL
BUDGET IS PROPOSING TO RUN THAT
FUNDING THROUGH HOME. WOULD THAT
CHANGE YOUR ADMINISTRATION OF
THE FUNDING AT ALL OR IMPACT
YOUR ABILITY TO PRIORITIZE THE
FUNDING FOR DEVELOPMENTS FOR
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
- YEAH WE DO ANTICIPATE MOST OF
THE FEDERAL RESERVE AS WELL LOW.
WHO WILL WELCOME HOME. BUT
LUCKILY WE TOOK THE ACTION ANY
TV IN EARLY TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
ACTUALLY CREATE STANDALONE
VISION. OF FEDERAL FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE BECAUSE WE WERE
TAKING ON SO MANY FEDERAL
RESOURCES IF YOU DON'T WE
ALREADY DID- SO THAT DIVISION
OVERSEES ALL FEDERAL RESOURCES
WHICH INCLUDE THE NATIONAL TRUST
FUND. AND HOME SO WE PARTICIPATE
IN CHALLENGES. THE POINT. THE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IF THERE
ARE NO QUESTIONS I KNOW WE HAVE
PLENTY OF. WE'RE GONNA. MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. MR ON
STATE. YES STILL APPRECIATE YOU
PROVIDING- TWO OF OUR REQUESTS
AROUND ADMINISTRATION
ADMINISTRATIVE ADMINISTRATIVE
RESOURCES SO- THIS IS TO-
ESSENTIALLY HELPLESS RIGHT SIZE
OF THE DEPARTMENT FOR ALL THE
GROUP THAT HAS BEEN OCCURRING-
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS-
PROGRAMMATIC LEE OF COURSE ALL
THE RESOURCES WE'VE GOTTEN BOTH
START FEDERAL AND STATE. ALL THE
DOZENS OF NEW HOUSING BILLS THIS
ALL COME WITH WORKLOAD FORCIBLY
BEEN QUITE APPRECIATIVE OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN. OFTEN LOOKING UP
IN THE FOR GIVING US THOSE
POSITIONS TO IMPLEMENT THOSE
LONGPROGRAMS ONE THING THAT
HAPPENED OF COURSE IS SOME OF
THE SUPPORT FUNCTIONS- ARE NOT
CONTEMPLATED ALL THE TIME AND
THAT'S A FLAT RATE SO IF YOU
GROW AS WE HAVE QUITE
SIGNIFICANTLY. OVER THE PAST
COUPLE YEARS. I THINK THAT.
MISSION RIGHT IF YOU AND IN THE
BACK THERE- YOU EE YOU SEE A
NEED ACROSS. OTHER FOLKS THAT
ARE SUPPORT LOCATIONS RIGHT-
WHEN IT COMES TO I. T. WHEN IT
COMES TO HUMAN RESOURCES. WHAT
IT COMES TO. THOSE AFFECTED. SO
THAT THE BULK OF THEIR BUSES
WITH THE RIGHT RIGHT SIDE FOR
TWENTY FIVE POSITIONS THERE-
WITH THE ADDITIONAL REQUEST FOR
THREE POSITIONS FOR- I LOVE TO
DO A LITTLE BIT MORE BY WAY. OF
MOBILE PHONE MAKE IT. INTO
ALLOWED THREE MORE SPECTER'S. US
INTO THAT FUNCTIONS- WE
OBVIOUSLY HAVE A LOT OF A LOCAL
PARTS OF THE STATE. WE ARE
UNDERGOING. EVALUATION CURRENTLY
ALSO IN YOU KNOW MANY OF THOSE
FUNCTIONS ARE OUR OR- OUR-
FUNDED THROUGH THE VARIOUS FEES
THAT ARE IMPOSED UPON MOBILE
HOME PARKS. WERE AT WORK THEY'RE
GOING TO BE A VALUATION. ON THAT
ASPECT AS WELL BUT IN THE
MEANTIME WE ARE SEEING. A BIG
NEED HELP FILLING WHAT. I TALK
ABOUT. ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE PARKS HOW THIS FLIES. FIVE
MILLION WE WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO MORE OF THESE PARKS ARE
REGULAR BASIS- AND THREE MORE
BECAUSE WITHOUT TO AT LEAST
INCREASE VOTER. THANK YOU MISTER
ANSETT MY PAUL THAT I SAYING
LAST NAME. AND INCORRECTLY MY
BILINGUAL. OF BRAIN KEEP
SHIFTING ON ME WE'RE GONNA GO.
THANK YOU- MISS MORALES WITH
ALLEY A PLACE. THANK YOU I THINK
DISCUSS THE DEPARTMENT
MINISTERING TO THE MARGIN
FUSIONS OF- AUGMENTATIONS IN
RECENT YEARS AND SO RIGHT SIZING
THEIR STAFFING- CORRESPONDINGLY
IT ALSO WE HAVE TO KNOW ISSUES
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT. CHRIS
CROOK DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS BUT AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU IS
THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS OF
THE DIETS WE'RE GOING TO GO ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER SIX- MISTER
ANSETT EUROPE AGAIN. THANK A LOT
OF MEAT THERE I THINK I'M GONNA
DO ALL THE PROPOSAL TODAY. FOR
ALL THE DEPARTMENTS THAT THE K.
THIS GETTING ARE PREFIGURED
BUILDINGS ON THE OTHER ON THE ON
THE FINAL ITEM HERE THIS IS AN
AUGMENTATION- IF YOU ARE ON THE
I. T. FROM FOR US- AS WAS NOTED
IN THE PREVIOUS ITEM- THERE'S A
LOT OF GROWTH THAT WE HAVE
UNDERGONE ITS DEPARTMENTS IN
TERMS OF PROGRAMS IN TERMS OF.
THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING WERE-
HISTORY THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
THE NUMBER FORCES THAT WERE
MISTR AND- YOU KNOW LIKE NOT
LIKE PROBABLY PROBABLY MANY MANY
AREAS WE HAVE- THE NEED FOR
MODERNIZATION OF OUR OF OUR I.
T. SYSTEM AND OUR ABILITY TO
TRACK THIS INFORMATION. SPELL
THIS WILL ALLOW IT TO THE FINAL
FINAL PHASES OF. THE PROCUREMENT
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF A NEW. I
HE SAID. TO BETTER ALL IN ALL OF
OUR BRAND LOW AND OTHER FOLKS-
THAT WE- YOU KNOW. PROVIDE IT
LOOKS ROBUST. LATELY DATA AND
INFORMATION AS POSSIBLE. THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT I'M SORRY L. L.
THANK YOU FOR TALKING ABOUT
TODAY THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
LEGISLATIVE INTERESTED IN POKER
SITE AND SO ON YOU CAN PROVE
CHANNELS AND MAKING SURE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CAT BETTER
ACCESS TO DATA WHICH WILL SERVE
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD HELP ACHIEVE
IT IS REASONABLE TO HAVE NO
ISSUES TO RAISE WITH THIS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. CHRIS COOK APARTMENT
FINANCE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS FOR YOU
MISTER ONSTED- SO LET ME JUST
TRY TO FRAME IT ALL TOGETHER
BECAUSE I DO THINK THERE ARE.
COMBINED AND CAN GIVE US A
BETTER PERSPECTIVE AS TO. HOW DO
WE LOOK AT THE ENTIRE PROJECT
HOW LONG WILL IT TAKE H. C. D.
TWO TRANSFERS DATA FROM THE
LEGACY SYSTEM TO THE NEW SUFFERS
A SOFTWARE SOLUTION HOWEL H. C.
D. ENSURE THAT THE DATA THAT HAS
BEEN- THAT HAS BEEN USING WORK
AROUNDS IS ACCURATELY REFLECTED
IN THE NEW SYSTEM AND WHY HAS IT
TAKEN SO LONG TO PRIORITIZE.
THIS CHANGE. SO I DO OVER CHAU
HERE BUT LIKE HIM TO BE ABLE TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION FOR YOU- IF
THERE'S A PARTY FROM THE
CERTAINLY BEEN A GOAL OF THE
DEPARTMENT FOR A WHILE- AND AS
YOU KNOW- WE HAVE TO WORK THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY AND SO WE
HAVE. BEEN DOING THAT FOR THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS AND THIS IS
THE FINAL PIECE OF THE PUZZLE SO
TO SPEAK TO ALLOW US TO DEPLOY
AFTER KERMIT- ED OBVIOUSLY WE'VE
BEEN DOING A LOT OF DATA CLEANUP
AND WE'VE BEEN DOING A LOT OF-
FINANCIAL. YOU KNOW. RESOLUTION
OF OUR- EVEN IN THAT INTERIM.
BUT WE ARE FINDING THAT AS WE
GROW WE NEED A NEW WATER STE.
AND THAT. THIS PROPOSAL. TODAY
IT'S NOT THAT WE'RE JUST PAYING
ATTENTION NOW IS THAT WE- HE HAD
THIS INFLUX OF FUNDING. AND WE
NEED TO DO IT- A LOT CLEARED IN
PREPARATION FOR THIS WE HAD. THE
LLOYDS UNDER CONTRACT THEY WERE
HELPING US RECONCILE ALL
REPREHENSIBLE MEANS THE DATA ON
FOR THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS OF
COURSE THAT WE MODERNIZE OUR
SYSTEM- IT CAN'T ACCOMMODATE.
ALL THE NEW CHANGED- PROGRAMS AT
ALL THAT THE VOLUME OF PROGRAMS
BY FRANKLY. THE FEDERAL AND
STATE SYSTEM THAT THE OLDER
SYSTEM AND- WE'VE REQUESTED AS
FAR IT CAN GO SO TO SPEAK. YOU
SEE THIS REQUEST BUT HOPEFULLY
TOMORROW IF YOU ARE ON IF YOU
COULD- SOME OF THE TIME
QUESTIONS IN A SPECIFIC. YES I'D
GO. AM HERE- PLAN COMPLETION FOR
THIS PROJECT IS- GENERAL TO COME
AND TWENTY FOUR WE ARE NOT TO
START WORKING CAPS ALL SOLICITOR
WILL HOW DO FOR STATE COULD NOT
PROGRAMS I DON'T PROGRAM HOW
UNITS AND WILL PUT REPORTS WE-
ANY. THOSE DETAILS SINCE ZACKS
SECTOR MAY HAVE. WE HAVE LIKE
BECOMES OR- DATA OVER THE PHONE
OF HUMAN WITH DEADLINE WE ARE
PLAYING THOSE LESS LEARNED.
TABLE COUNTRY THE SAME DIFFICULT
. OUR PROJECTS MANAGEMENT IMAGE
AS WELL. UNITS AND THANKS LIKE
THAT WE HAD ALL PUT. FOR THE
DATA WISH SO JOHN TWO THOUSAND
FOUR OUR TWENTY FOUR HOUR
GRUELING TO COME ON WITH DATA TO
THE KINGS WOULD WOULD BE A-
ENTERPRISE DAY. OKAY THAT I I'M
AND YOU FOR THAT. BY J. OF
TWENTY FIVE. THE ENTIRE SYSTEM
HAVE BEEN TRANSFERRED OVER TO
THE NEW STUFF SO KARAN. YES OKAY
AND IS THERE IS THERE A PROCESS
IN PLACE TO ASSURE THAT THE DATA
THAT HAS BEEN USING WORK AROUNDS
WILL BE ACCURATELY REFLECTED IN
THE NEW SYSTEM. YES WE DO HAVE A
PROCESS IN PLACE- SHUT
UNDERGARMENTS- SUCH AS NUMBER OF
YOUR MAKES THE- USED TO BE THAT
FEDERAL OF STATE FUNDING PROGRAM
. HELLO IN MARCH SCHOOLS IN THE
PROCESS FINDING WATER MONSTERS
SEE IN THE NEWS BUT THERE TO
EACH MORE THAN WELCOME. THE DATA
THAT DOES CUT MORE DRUG MUST
SOLVE SO HELD PLACE. THANK YOU
SIR MUCH OF. THAT I THINK IF
THERE ARE NO WHAT. QUESTIONS WE
ARE GOING WRAP. WITH THE THIS
PART. HOLD ON ONE MOMENT LET ME
GET MYSELF ORGANIZED HERE MAKE
SURE THAT I HAVE EVERYTHING
CORRECT. YES WE ARE DONE WITH
THAT THESE PARTICULAR ISSUES MR
ON SAID I'M GOING TO ASK THAT
YOU STAY ON AND PERCENT FOR THE
REST OF THE ADDITIONAL PANELS.
IF THAT'S OKAY. I THINK YOU'RE
YOU'RE CUTTING RIGHT THE
APPRECIATE OU GUYS AND BUILDING
ME UP FOR SO LONG. PLEASE LET US
KNOW I KNOW THERE'S A LOT A LOT
GOING ON IN THE STATE SO. WE ARE
HAPPY IT COULD BE RESOURCES AS
WE- THANK YOU I DO SOMETIMES
THINK WE NEED A MOMENT OF LEVITY
APPRECIATE YOU AND- THANK YOU
FOR. ANSWERING ALL OF OUR
QUESTIONS WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK. TO PERCENTAGE. LET ME GET
MYSELF ORGANIZED. ISSUE NUMBER
ONE THANK YOU- THE COMMISSION ON
THE STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS
WELCOME. YOU. OUR FIRST IN
PERSON PRESENTER AND TUFF FOR
THIS YEAR WELCOME VERY COOL WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. WHAT IT'S FOR MY CON.
MAKE SURE THERE ARE MICROPHONES
ON HELLO HELLO. OKAY CAN YOU ALL
HEAR ME OKAY OKAY GREAT- THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY MY NAME IS HOLLY MARTINEZ
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS. ARE
EXCITED TO BE HERE TO BE YOUR
FIRST PERSON- TO JOIN YOU IN
PERSON- AFTER ALL THIS TIME AND
TO BE ABLE TO DELIVER OUR ANNUAL
REPORTS WHICH I HOPE YOU GET YOU
GET A CHANCE TO SORT OF THOUSAND
THROUGH AT YOUR LEISURE. AT THE
COMMISSION YOU KNOW WE ARE WE
WORK IN A CULTURALLY INCLUSIVE
MANNER TO PROMOTE EQUITY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL WOMEN AND GIRLS
AND TO ADD AN OFFER PERSPECTIVE
TO THE LEGISLATURE AND TO THE
GOVERNOR ABOUT WHAT THE NEEDS OF
WOMEN ARE AT THE POLICY LEVEL.
RIGHT NOW BUT WOMEN NEED IS TO
B FRONT AND CENTER IN A FULLY
EQUITABLE ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA OR WERE
ALREADY STRUGGLING TO PAY THEIR
BILLS PRIOR TO THE ONSET OF THE
ECONOMIC CRISIS BROUGHT ON BY
THE PANDEMIC. CALIFORNIA WOMEN
FACE SIGNIFICANT WAGE GAPS.
ALONG WITH OPPORTUNITY GAPS THAT
MEAN THAT EVEN PRE PANDEMIC
WOMEN WERE MORE LIKELY THAN MEN
TO EARN LOW WAGES AND LIVE IN
POVERTY. THE COPA NINETY
RECESSION WAS THE FIRST
RECESSION IN WHICH MORE WOMEN
THAN MEN LOST JOBS WHILE MEN
HAVE NOT RECOUPED ALL THEIR JOBS
IN ACCORDING TO A RECENT REPORT
FROM THE PANDEMIC ONE MILLION
FEWER WOMEN ARE STILL. ARE ONE
MILLION FEWER WOMEN ARE IN THE
WORK FORCE TODAY THAN AT THE
START OF THE PANDEMIC. THE SHARP
CONTRAST BETWEEN THE NUMBER OF
MEN AND WOMEN IN THE LABOR WORK
FORCE LIKELY REFLECTS THE AN
EVEN CARE GIVING
RESPONSIBILITIES MEN AND WOMEN
HAVE TAKEN INTO THE PANDEMIC.
WHICH HAVE CAUSED CONTINUED
DISRUPTION IN SCHOOL AND CARE
GIVING RESPONSIBILITIES WE KNOW
BLACK AND LYFT NEXT WOMEN AND
WOMEN WHO ARE IMMIGRANTS LOST
THEIR JOBS AT ESPECIALLY HIGH
RATES IN THE EARLY MONTHS OF THE
PANDEMIC. TO PUT IT IN REAL
TERMS LOST WAGES EQUALS RENT
THAT CAN'T BE PAID FALLING
BEHIND IN MORTGAGES DIFFICULTY
AFFORDING FOOD FOR THEIR
FAMILIES. NOT BEING ABLE TO SAVE
MONEY FOR HOMES AND IT MEANS
LESS RETIREMENT SAVINGS IN THE
LONG TERM. THESE KINDS OF
ECONOMIC HURDLES CAN SHAPE A
WOMEN'S FINANCIAL SECURITY AND
THAT OF HER FAMILY FOR AN ENTIRE
GENERATION OR MORE. IT'S AGAINST
THIS BACKDROP AT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS THAT WE HAVE
EMERGED UNDER NEW LEADERSHIP
WITH NEW MEMBERS TO LEAD THE
CHARGE IN CREATING A GENDER
EQUITABLE RECOVERY PLAN. WOMEN
HAVE BEGUN WE HAVE BEGUN THIS
WORK AT THE COMMISSION STARTING
WITH THE WOMEN'S RECOVERY GRANT
PROGRAM A FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME FUNDING TO SUPPORT
WOMEN'S. MOST URGENT NEEDS. THE
COMMISSION HAS RECENTLY APPROVED
THE FINAL SELECTION OF OUR
GRANTEES. TO SAY THERE WAS AN
INTEREST IN THIS OPPORTUNITY IS
AN UNDERSTATEMENT. WE HAD NEARLY
THREE SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY
APPLICANTS APPLYING FOR MORE
THAN SIXTY THREE MILLION AND
REQUESTS FOR FUNDING ALONE. WITH
ONLY FIVE MILLION WE CAN FIND
JUST 20% OF ALL THE REQUESTS
HAVE COME IN TO RESPOND TO SOME
IMMEDIATE URGENT NEEDS OF WOMEN.
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC. WE ARE
ALSO USING THIS GRANT FUNDING
OPPORTUNITY TO FURTHER
STRENGTHEN THE EXISTING NETWORK
OF LOCAL COMMISSIONS AS WELL AS
ESTABLISH NEW LOCAL COMMISSIONS
TO IMPROVE REPRESENTATION AND
ACCESS. FOR ALL WOMEN ACROSS THE
STATE. CURRENTLY THERE ARE LESS
THAN THIRTY LOCAL COMMISSIONS
COVERING ONLY FOURTEEN COUNTIES
ALL OF WHICH ARE OUR MOST OF
WHICH ARE COASTAL COUNTIES.
LEAVING OUT CRITICAL VOICES
PERSPECTIVES AND NEEDS OF
DIVERSE AND UNDERREPRESENTED
WOMEN AND GIRLS. WE ARE WORKING
TO CHANGES AT THE COMMISSION BUT
THIS IS JUST THE START. WE NEED
MORE FUNDING TO DO MORE FOR
WOMEN WHO ARE MORE THAN HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION. OUR
PROPOSAL FOR INCREASED POSITIONS
WILL ALLOW US TO DEDICATE STAFF
FOR STRATEGIC OUT REACHING
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS AMONG
LOCAL DIVERSE AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT OF OUR
BUDGET THE PROPOSAL FOR THE
COMMISSION. SO WE CAN FURTHER
BRING WHAT WE'RE LEARNING AND
DOING TO OTHER STATE AGENCIES TO
BRING GENDER EQUITY IN
PERSPECTIVE ON BEHALF OF WOMEN
AND GIRLS TO THE AT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISS MARTINEZ LET'S GO
TO THE L. L. PLEASE.
CONTEMPLATED ANALYST'S OFFICE
OUT WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSAL. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AFTERNOON TO MEMBER DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NOTED YOUR COMMENTS
BUT I HAVE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THANK
YOU MISS MARTINEZ- I JUST WANT
TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT UNDER THE
DIRECTION AND LEADERSHIP OF OUR
SPEAKER I WAS- APPROVED TO HAVE
THE SELECT COMMITTEE AND YOUNG
GIRLS AND WOMEN OF COLOR AND
BECAUSE OF COLD BUT THERE'S BEEN
VERY LIMITED THINGS THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DO AND I APPLAUD
YOUR POSITION NOW WITH THE
COMMISSION AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ENSURING THAT THERE'S- LEVEL
AVENUE IN WHICH WE ADDRESS SOME
OF THE MORE PRESSING CONCERNS
THAT YOU HAVE TALKED ABOUT TODAY
AND- ULTIMATELY AT THE END OF
THE DAY FIND A PATHWAY. IN WHICH
WE PROVIDE UP. TRINITY FOR.
YOUNG GIRLS AND WOMEN OF COLOR
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SO. WITH THAT- CAN I GET A
MOTION TO APPROVE THIS. THANK
YOU AND I WILL SECOND. ROLL CALL
CREON HI COOPER LACKEY IN THIS
AREA WICKS HI. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ON ONE LAST WORD
WE ARE STARTING A GIRL SUB
COMMITTEE AT THE COMMISSION AND
SO I REALLY WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK TOGETHER ON
YOUR SELECT COMMITTEE AND-
CONTINUE THAT PATH FORWARD THANK
YOU SO MUCH MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MADAM CHAIR. HAVE A
GREAT DAY. THANK YOU. WE ARE
GOING BACK ON THE AGENDA TO
ISSUE SEVEN. ONE MOMENT GET
MYSELF ORGANIZED HERE- MISS
MELINDA GRANTS ARE YOU ON THE
LINE AND IF SO YOU MAY BEGIN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN CARRILLO
IN THE GROWTH OF THE COMMUNITY
AND COMING AFTER THAT
PRESENTATION HAPPY WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH IT'S ALL OF THE
WOMEN AND GIRLS OUT THERE
INCLUDING MY FOUR YEAR OLD WHO
MAY BE WATCHING YOU HAS NO IDEA
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT BUT JUST
KNOW THAT. AND TO ON BILLION
WOMAN OUT THERE AND IT'S A GREAT
TIME. WITH. I'M SORRY I THANK
YOU MUCH APPRECIATE THAT.
ABSOLUTELY AND AGAIN MY NAME IS
MONEY GRANTS AND UNDERSECRETARY
HERE AT THE BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES AND HOUSING AGENCY THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU TODAY
REQUEST RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
WORKLOAD STINGING FROM AN
INCREASED OVERSIGHT AND
STRATEGIC COORDINATION REQUIRED
TO SUPPORT EXISTING AGENCY
PROGRAMS AND SIGNIFICANT GROWTH
IN NEW PROGRAMS POSSIBILITIES
PACIFIC LANE AREA OF HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AGENCY CONTRACTED WITH A
MANAGEMENT CONSULTING FIRM TO
IDENTIFY POTENTIAL OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES IN STAFFING GAPS
THAT EXIST IN THE CURRENT
OPERATING STRUCTURE IN THIS
PROPOSAL REFLECTS OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS I NEED JOINT
FIRE DEPUTY SECRETARY FISCAL
POLICY ADMINISTRATION. SYDNEY
GARCIA AND OUR DEFENSE SECRETARY
OF HOUSING SUCH CONTENT AND
WE'RE. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU I SECRETARY GRAN BEFORE WE
MOVE FOR. TAKE ROLL CALL FOR THE
PREVIOUS- ITEM ISSUE NUMBER ONE
ON THE STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS
. NAZARIAN HI. THANK YOU LET'S
GO ON TO GO BACK TO ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN- LA- MISS MORALES. I THINK
YOU LOOK MARVELOUS WITH THE L.
L. WHAT THE AGENCY HAS SORT OF
BROADER RESPONSIBILITIES AS-
DISCUSSED EARLIER IN THE AT
JUMPED OUT ON THE
RESPONSIBILITIES RELATED TO
HAVING HOMELESSNESS CERTAINLY
INCREASED IN RECENT YEARS ANSWER
RIGHT FIGHTING EACH OF THE IN
THAT CONTEXT IS REASONABLE AND
WE HAVE NO ISSUES TO RAISE WITH
THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ENTER HOW
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU JUST A COUPLE
QUESTIONS OVER THE YEARS B. C.
S. H. HAS GROWN IN SIZE DUE TO
SOME OF THE HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS BEING PLACED AT THE
ENTRANCE AGENCY- VERSUS H. CD
HAS A GROWN IN SIZE. THE AGENCY
ITSELF. YES YES YES THE AGENCY
HAS HAS GROWN IN SIZE AND GOING
BACK TO WHEN WE GET FIRST AND
STARTED WITH AND ACROSS THE
AGENCY IN GENERAL AND GOING UP
FROM I THINK A LITTLE UNDER SIX
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES AGENCY BY TWO
CLOSER TO SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
BATES OF COURSE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT ADDRESSES BUT WE HAVE
BEEN WITH THE AGENCY ITSELF AND
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD REFLECT NEW
POSITIONS ADDED ON- ST STE THE
NEW ADDITION AT THE ARMORY WHICH
BECAME AT THE PARTNER WITHIN THE
AGENCY AS WELL AS THE PART IN
THE CANNABIS CONTROL THEN OF
COURSE THE CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL WHICH IS
ANOTHER ENTITY THAT FALLS WITHIN
THE AGENCY ITSELF. AND DOES THE
AGENCY INTO. FUTURE HOMELESS
PROGRAMS CONTINUE TO BE PLACED
AT THE AGENCY OR MOVED TO
ANOTHER LOCATION. YOU KNOW AT
THIS TIME HERE ESPECIALLY DO THE
AGE OF TWENTY WHICH I KNOW THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MANY OF THE
NUMBERS IN THE GOVERNOR PASSED
RECENTLY REGARDING THE RECENT
RESTRUCTURING OF COW ICIJ AND
HAVING A CO CHAIR HOUSING AND
HEALTH IN THIS IS YOU KNOW THAT
IS DEFINITELY. OUR CHARGE AHEAD
COMING OUT OF A STRONG FIRST
QUARTER WITH MANY STATUTORY
GOALS AND SO AND THAT IS WHERE
OUR FOCUS IS AND THAT'S WHERE
WE'RE AT WAITING TO CONTINUE
LOOKING FORWARD. THANK YOU MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT IF THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE MEMBERS- WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT
AND CAPMAN RESOLUTION GRANTS-
MISTER DERON ARE YOU ONE AND IF
SO- PLEASE- PLEASE BEGIN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS VICTOR DRAWN HERE WE'RE
HAVING A HARD TIME HEARING YOU
PLEASE BE CLOSER INTO THE MIKE
PLACE. IS THIS BETTER. YES BUT-
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS
BICKERED AROUND HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA INTERAGENCY COUNCIL
ON HOMELESSNESS AND I APPRECIATE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS WITH
YOU THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL UP FOR A FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME THE
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION AND
ACCOMPANYING TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE CHANGES TO PROVIDE
LOCAL ENTITIES WITH GRANTS IN
SUPPORT OF PERMANENT HOUSING
SOLUTIONS FOR CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCING UNSHELTERED
HOMELESSNESS AND FOR RESOLVING
CRITICAL IN CAMDEN ISSUES ACROSS
THE STATE. THIS REQUEST BUILT ON
THE FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR ONE
TIME IN CAMP AND RESOLUTION
PROGRAM THAT WAS ESTABLISHED FOR
THIS FISCAL YEAR AND WHICH WE
ARE CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
IMPLEMENTING. THIS FIRST
ITERATION OF THE PROGRAM WE
RECEIVE REQUESTS TO FUND A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS A PROJECTS FROM DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF COMMUNITY
MEMBERS LIVING IN ENCAMPMENTS.
THE NEED FOR A MUCH LARGER SCALE
PROGRAM IS FURTHER REFLECTED IN
THE MOST RECENT POINT IN TIME
COUNT OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WERE IN OVER TWO
THIRDS OF CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WERE
SHOWN TO BE EXPERIENCING.
UNSHELTERED HOMELESSNESS THE
HIGH STREET IN THE NATION. SO
THIS REQUEST WOULD ALLOW US TO
FURTHER INVEST IN FLEXIBLE AND
INNOVATIVE ENCAMPMENT RESOLUTION
STRATEGIES. AND TECHNIQUES THAT-
AT THE SCALE AND WITH THE
URGENCY THAT'S NEEDED TO RESOLVE
THIS CRISIS- I WOULD WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
AND I ALSO HAVE WITH ME-
COLLEAGUES FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
ON THE LINE. TO RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THAT FALL
UNDER THEIR PURVIEW. THANK YOU
CAN HEAR FROM THE ALLEY A PLACE
. THE DALLAS WITH THE L. A. O.
OUR OFFICE RELEASED AN ANALYSIS
OF THE GOVERNOR'S OVERALL I'M
HOMELESSNESS- BUDGET PACKAGE
THIS YEAR WITH WHICH THIS IS
JUST ONE COMPONENT SUCH AS FOCUS
MY COMMENTS ON THE ACCOUNT
RESOLUTION THE SUBJECT OF. OF
THE ISSUE BEFORE YOU AS WAS
NOTED IN THE ADMINISTRATION
PRESENTATION OF THIS PROPOSAL
WITH SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDS THE
SCOPE OF THE PRIOR YEAR
APPLICATION UP FROM FIFTY
MILLION TO- FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
AND SINCE THIS IS A VERY LARGE
INCREASE IN THE SCOPE- IT'S
REALLY CHALLENGING TO A THIRD
AFFECT HOW THE CENTERPIECE YOU
SENSE THERE'S VERY LITTLE
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT ONE TIME
PUBLICATION LAST YEAR. AND SO WE
WOULD JUST RAISE QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE PERFORMANCE WITH FAST- WHICH
TYPES OF INNOVATIONS YOU DON'T
HAVE BEEN MORE SUCCESSFUL IT'S
JUST SOMETHING THAT WITH THE
TIMELINE THE LEGISLATURE WILL
REALLY. NOT BE ABLE TO SORT OF-
THOSE ISSUES. HOW TO SORT OF BE
FINE THE PROGRAM. TO REALLY NEED
TO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. GOOD
AFTERNOON BRITNEY THOMPSON
APARTMENT FINANCE NOTHING ADD
THIS TIME BUT AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU I DO HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS ACTUALLY HOW DOES
A CAL I. CH PLAN TO ACCES THE
OUTCOMES OF THE FIRST ROUND OF
FUNDING AND WHEN WILL THAT DATA
BE AVAILABLE. THANK YOU FOR THE
THIRTY SEVEN THAT'S NOT ACCESS-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MANAGER SO
THERE'S A NUMBER OF MEASURES
THAT WE'RE PUTTING IN PLACE TO
CONTINUOUSLY COLLECT AND ASSESS
THE OUTCOMES OF THIS FIRST
ITERATION OF THE PROGRAM- WE
WILL BE REQUIRING OUR GRANTEES
TO PROVIDE ORDERLY PROGRAMMATIC
REPORTS- THAT WE WILL BE
ANALYZING ON AN ONGOING BASIS WE
WILL BE REQUIRING OUR GRANTEES
TO ENTER THEIR DATA ON THE
PEOPLE THEY INTEND TO SERVE-
INTO THE SYSTEM THAT FEEDS UP
INTO THE STATE WIDE ALMOST THE
STATE INTEGRATION SYSTEM SO THAT
WE CONTRACT. SERVICES AND
OUTCOMES TO THE INDIVIDUAL LEVEL
WE ALSO TEND TO- ESTABLISH A
CONTRACT WITH THE RESEARCH AND
EVALUATION FORM THAT WILL
CONDUCT A DEEPER LEVEL OF OUR
ASSESSMENT OF THE PROGRAM HAS A
WHOLE BOTH ITS DESIGN
IMPLEMENTATION AND ITS ULTIMATE
OUTCOMES AFTER THE PROGRAM
CONCLUDES- AND WITH RESPECT TO
WIN THE STATE WILL BECOME
AVAILABLE OF COURSE IT WILL
HAPPEN OVER THE COURSE OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROGRAM-
AS YOU ARE ALL AWARE WE HAVE
RECENTLY ANNOUNCED HE INTENDED
AWARD HE'S FOR THIS FIRST
ITERATION OF THE PROGRAM- AND WE
ARE CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
ENTERING INTO CONTRACTS WITH
THOSE GUARANTEES. SO AT ONCE
THOSE PROGRAMS ARE STOOD UP WE
EXPECT TO RECEIVE OUR FIRST
QUARTERLY REPORT LATE AT THE END
OF THIS YEAR AND HAVE SOME
INITIAL DATA SHORTLY THEREAFTER
OF COURSE RECOGNIZING THAT THAT
DATA WILL BECOME OF MORE REMOTE
ROOM MORE ROBUST AS PROGRAMS ARE
STOOD UP AND THERE'S TIME FOR
THE SERVICE DELIVERY. STRATEGIES
TO BE IMPLEMENTED. DOES THE IN
CAP SO WHAT YOU MENTIONED THAT
THE DATA FOR THE FIFTY MILLION
THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN ALLOCATED
AND BEING WORKED ON WILL BE
AVAILABLE WHEN ONE WILL THAT
REPORT BE READY. THE FIRST SET
OF DATA WE ANTICIPATE TOWARDS
THE END OF THIS YEAR AND THEN
QUARTERLY DATA WILL BE AVAILABLE
THEREAFTER. OKAY AND SO JUST ONE
OF. BETTER UNDERSTAND THAT AS AS
THAT MOVES FORWARD AS THE
INCOMING PROGRAM HAVE THE SAME
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES THAT
WERE CREATED FOR HAVE PROGRAMS
LAST YEAR. G. KEVIN THE CURRENT
AND CABIN RESOLUTION PROGRAM-
COUNTERBALANCE GOALS ARE A
LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN FOR HALF.
THE HALF THE HOUSING THE HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
IS DESIGNED TO SUPPORT THE
ENTIRE HOMELESSNESS RESPONSE
SYSTEM AND SO THE PERFORMANCE
GOALS THAT WE DESIGNED FOR THAT
PROGRAM WERE SPECIFIC TO.
MEASURING OUTCOMES FOR THE
SYSTEM AT LARGE WHEREAS FORTY
EVEN CAPTAIN RESOLUTION PROGRAM
SINCE THE- OPPOSED PROJECTS ARE
VERY TARGETED- WE WANTED TO ZERO
WE HAD OUR PERFORMANCE GOALS
AROUND THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
SERVED AND THE SPECIFIC OUTCOMES
ACHIEVED WITH THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
FORTY PROPOSED A PROGRAM- WE
WOULD BE ADDING ADDITIONAL
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES AND
PERFORMANCE GOLD MEASURES- AND
YES THEY ARE IN ALIGNMENT WITH
THE CAP PROGRAM THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED THESE INCLUDE
ENHANCED MONITORING AUTHORITY
FOR CALLIE C. H. TO INSURE-
APPROPRIATE USE OF FUNDS. THIS
INCLUDES A- INTERIM GOAL PERIOD
WHERE ELIGIBLE ENTITIES UPON
MEETING THOSE GOALS MAY BECOME
ELIGIBLE FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDS-
AND THIS ALSO INCLUDES
ESTABLISHING REALLY SPECIFIC
PROGRAM GOALS AS PART OF EVERY
PROPOSAL INCLUDING THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUAL SERVERS. THE NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUAL SERVERS WHO ENTER
INTO- IT HARD SHELLED HER
PERMANENT HOUSING THE FINAL
STATUS OF THE ENCAMPMENTS SITE
THAT'S BEING SERVED AND ALL OF
THE SUPPORT OF SERVICES THAT ARE
RICH. THANK YOU MR DERON. YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE HAVE WITH OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE AS WE TRY TO
ADDRESS THE BIGGEST PROBLEM THAT
WE FACE ASK THE STATE WITH
RELATIONS TO HOUSING IN OUR OWN
HOUSE RESIDENTS BUT PARTICULARLY
THE GROWTH OF ENCAMPMENTS.
YOU'RE ASKING YOU'RE GOING FROM
FIFTY MILLION. TO FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION. WE ARE LESS THAN ONE
HUNDRED DAYS AWAY FROM CLOSING
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET BUT YOUR
REPORT ON THE FIFTY MILLION
WON'T BE AVAILABLE UNTIL THE END
OF THE YEAR. HOW IS THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE. SUCH AN
IMPORTANT. DECISION ON
ALLOCATING PUBLIC DOLLARS WHEN
WE DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE
MEASUREMENTS OF SUCCESS. YES A
VERY VALID CONCERN MAKING PART
OF WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO BALANCE
IS HAVING GOOD DATA AND
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES FOR THE
PROGRAMS ARE IN PLACE BUT ALSO
ACTING WITH URGENCY AND SPEED IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THE SIZE AND
SCOPE OF THIS ISSUE- PART OF
WHAT INFORMED OUR REQUEST IT IS.
FOR THIS FIRST ITERATION OF THE
PROGRAM WE RECEIVED THIRTY NINE
PROPOSALS REPRESENTING ALL TYPES
OF COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE-
BUT WE WERE ONLY ABLE TO FIND
ONE THIRD OF THEM. AND MANY OF
THE COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
WHO SUBMITTED PROPOSALS LET US
KNOW THAT HAD MORE FUNDING
AVAILABLE THEY WOULD HAVE SAID
IN MULTIPLE PROPOSALS TO- PEOPLE
IN MULTIPLE ENCAMPMENTS WITHIN
THEIR JURISDICTIONS. ALL OF THIS
OF COURSE IS REFLECTED IN THE
DATA THAT WE DO HAVE AVAILABLE
INDICATING THAT OVER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS ARE
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING
UNSHELTERED HOMELESSNESS AND SO
WHILE CERTAINLY WE APPRECIATE
THE NEED OR I'M AS MUCH WILL
BUST DATA AS POSSIBLE- IN.
SUPPORT OF OUR INVESTMENTS YOU
KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO BALANCE
THAT WITH THE URGENCY OF THE
CRISIS THAT WE. CURRENTLY
ANNAPOLIS. THANK YOU. SO OUT OF
THE THIRTY NINE PROPOSALS ONE
THIRD WERE GRANTED. I'M JUST
LOOKING AT PAGE THIRTY EIGHT FOR
A MARIN COUNTY THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND. WERE
ALLOCATED TO ROUTE CALLS
EIGHTEEN. INDIVIDUALS HOW. I'M
I'M HAVING A HARD TIME TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE COSTS AND WHAT IS
THE STATUS OF THOSE EIGHTEEN
INDIVIDUALS THAT COST THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS. SAID THE PROGRAM IS
CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
BEING IMPLEMENTED WE ARE RIGHT
NOW ARE PREPARING TO ENTER INTO
CONTRACTS WITH THE DIFFERENT-
GRANTEES WE RECEIVED A WIDE
RANGE OF PROPOSALS- FOR A WIDE
RANGE OF DOLLAR AMOUNTS PER
PERSON SERVED. ADDED A SORT OF
MANY OF THOSE REFLECT THE INTENT
STRATEGIES THAT THE COMMUNITY IS
GOING TO CARRY OUT- THE EAT
LOCAL RESOURCES THAT THEY ARE
ABLE TO LEVERAGE SO IN SOME
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY HAVE
OTHER PARTNERSHIPS ARE
RESOURCES. THAT THEY CAN
LEVERAGE THAT WILL HAVE AN
IMPACT ON THE COST PER
INDIVIDUAL START- BUT OF COURSE-
THE INTENT BEHIND THIS PROGRAM
IS TO ESTABLISH DEMONSTRATE
PROJECTS. I UNDERSTAND.
TRAGEDIES ARE MOST SUCCESSFUL
AND WHAT IS THE TRUE COST. FOR
SERVING INDIVIDUALS AND YOU KNOW
WHAT OF COURSE IS. OPEN HIGHEST
HOUSING COSTS STATES IT IN THE
NATION AND SERVING INDIVIDUALS
WHO OFTEN HAVE AMONG THE MOST
COMPLEX CONSTELLATION OF
OVERLAPPING NEEDS AND THEN OF
COURSE CORRESPONDING SERVICES
THAT NEED TO BE BROUGHT TO BEAR
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THIS. SO I
GUESS I GUESS IT MUST VERY SOME
LOOKING AT THIS TWENTY FOUR
POINT EIGHT MILLION TO RE HOUSE
A HUNDRED AND TWO INDIVIDUALS
THAT'S A- THAT'S AT A COST OF
ABOUT FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND PER
INDIVIDUAL. WHAT IS THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE
RESOURCES AND OPPORTUNITIES THAT
INDIVIDUALS FROM VARIOUS
DIFFERENT PLACES ARE RECEIVING.
AND WHAT LIKE TO. I GUESS TO IN
MANY WAYS UNDERSTAND THIS VAST
COST DIFFERENCE. THE DIFFERENCES
ARE OFTEN WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
EXISTING PROGRAMS AND RESOURCES
THAT THEY PLAN TO LEVERAGE SO
THERE MAY BE INSTANCES WHERE
THERE'S A COMMUNITY ALREADY HAS
A STRONG HOUSING PROJECT THAT
THEY'RE PREPARING TO BRING. AND
THE PRIMARY NEED THAT THEY HAVE
IS STREET OUTREACH SERVICES AND
HOUSING NAVIGATORS SO RELATIVELY
LOWER COSTS NEEDS THAT ARE
SUPPORTED BY DISCREET. THERE MAY
BE SOME INSTANCES WHERE SOME OF
THOSE ON THE GROUND SERVICES ARE
ALREADY AVAILABLE BUT IT'S MORE
CAPITAL EXPENDITURES WITH REPORT
WILL BE MORE COSTLY. THAT THAT'S
THE WHOLE THAT A FLEXIBLE GRANT
LIKE THIS IS ABLE TO FILL IN SO
THAT'S PART OF WHY USED IN THE
WIDER. IN THE RIGHT. COSTS THAT
ARE BEING FUNDED AND OF COURSE
PART OF THE INTENT BEHIND THIS
PROGRAM IS TO DO AN EVALUATION
OF THESE DIFFERENT DEMONSTRATION
MODELS. TO TEST FOR ADVOCATES.
SO IF I WERE TO ASK YOU WHAT
WERE THE RESOURCES IF MAYBE
PERHAPS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES THAT WERE OFFERED TO
THESE INDIVIDUALS DO YOU HAVE
THAT DATA AVAILABLE. NOT YET WE
WILL HAVE THAT DATA AVAILABLE
ONCE WE'VE ESTABLISHED THE
PROGRAMS AND ARE ABLE TO DO AN
ASSESSMENT OF THE INITIAL DATA
AND REPORTING BACK. AND THAT
WILL THAT WILL BE UNTIL THE END
OF THE YEAR. APPROXIMATELY YES
I'D OKAY I JUST I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT YOU'RE ASKING YOU HAD
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS WE HAVE
THE FUNDING THAT'S BEEN
ALLOCATED TO THE ONE THIRD OF
PROPOSALS THAT WERE GRANTED I'M
LOOKING AT L. A. COUNTY ALONE
ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION TO RE
HOUSE SIXTY INDIVIDUALS THAT'SABOUT THE SIZE OF THE ENCAMPMENT
THAT WE HAD IN ONE NEIGHBORHOOD.
IN MY DISTRICT. AND SO WHEN
WE'RE ASKING FOR INFORMATION AND
DATA TO BE ABLE TO FUND. PUBLIC
DOLLARS AT THE TUNE OF FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION. BEFORE JUNE
WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE DATA. HOW IS
THE LEGISLATURE SUPPOSED TO
RESPOND TO THAT. SOME OF THE
CONSIDERATIONS OF COURSE AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE THE SCOPE
INSIGHTS THE DATA THAT WE DO
PERHAPS REFLECTS THE SCOPE AND
SIZE. THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS- AND SO DO THE NUMBER OF
PROPOSALS THAT WE RECEIVED BUT
ALSO THE INFORMATION RECEIVED
ABOUT THE PROPOSALS THAT WERE
NOT SUBMITTED IN RECOGNITION OF
THE LIMITED RESOURCES. SO IT'S
HARD TO FIND THAT BALANCE
BETWEEN ACCOUNTABILITY AND
SCALING UP THE PROGRAM TO MEET
THE TO MEET THE NEED- WE ARE
GOING TO BE IMPLEMENTING SOME
ENHANCE ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES
FOR THIS NEW GENERATION OF THE
PROGRAM- AS I MENTIONED THAT ARE
MODELED AFTER HALF SO WE WILL BE
DOING ENHANCED MONITORING. AND
THIS WELL THAT WOULD. THAT BILL
LANGUAGE WHATEVER OUR I. C. H.
WITH ADDITIONAL MEASURES SUCH AS
REITS REQUIRING GRANTEES TO
REDIRECT THEIR FUNDS. OR TO READ
HOW TO KEEP THEIR FUNDS. OR
MAKING THEM INELIGIBLE FOR
FUTURE FUNDS IF IT'S PART OF OUR
ENHANCED MONITORING A WE ARE NOT
SEEKING A PERFORMANCE WERE NOT
SEEKING APPROPRIATE USE OF FIVE. YOU MENTIONED THAT THERE WAS A
ANOTHER COLLEAGUE OF YOURS ON
THE LINE THAT CAN SPEAK ON
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES. YES
HI I'M STEPHANIE WILSON THE
DEPUTY SECRETARY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH FOR THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY. THANK
YOU CAN YOU ELABORATE A BIT ON
SOME OF THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES THAT ARE BEING PROVIDED
TO. THE COUNTY THAT ARE LISTED
IN THE AGENDA. OR SHOULD I SAY
THE ONE THIRD OF THE THIRTY NINE
PROPOSALS OVER GRANTED. MADAM
CHAIR I AM I APOLOGIZE THAT I'M
NOT FAMILIAR WITH. THE SPECIFIC
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SERVICES THAT
ARE DELIVERED IT TO THE GRANTEES
OF THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM BUT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I CAN WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO GET BACK TO YOU
ON I. BELIEVE I WAS- I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THE BRIDGE HOUSING
PROPOSAL- THAT WE HAVE AS PART
OF OUR DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. PLEASE DO THANK YOU-
WELL CERTAINLY- SO IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET- WE ARE PROPOSING
AS PART OF OUR DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND THEY
OFFERED THEIR APOLOGIES- I'M A
STEPPING IN TODAY- FOR THEM. AT
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
THAT IS BEING PROPOSED FOR
HOUSING. AND THIS IS
SPECIFICALLY DEFINED CLINICALLY
ENHANCED A BRIDGE HOUSING
SETTINGS FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS HAVE
SERIOUS BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CONDITIONS. SO MENTAL HEALTH OR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS. THE
FUNDING WOULD BE ADMINISTERED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AS AN ADDITION TO OUR
CURRENT- BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CONTINUUM INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM THAT WE'RE OPERATING
RIGHT NOW. AND IT'S REALLY
INTENDED TO EITHER PURCHASE
INSTALLER OPERATE TINY HOMES OR
TO PREVENT OR TO COVER OPERATING
COSTS FOR. OTHER SETTINGS
SPECIFICALLY ADULT RESIDENTIAL
AND SENIOR CARE SETTINGS. FOR
OUR POPULATION THAT HAS THE MOST
CHRONIC BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS THESE ARE THE
SETTINGS IN WHICH THEY ARE MOST
OFTEN TO RESIDE SUCCESSFULLY.
AND IT DOES REQUIRE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF STAFF
SUPPORT- TO PROVIDE THEM BOTH
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
PHYSICAL HEALTH CARE NEEDS THAT
THEY- REQUIRE- AND DEAD. WE
INTEND TO WORK WITH THOSE
PROVIDERS TO LEVERAGE OUR-
CALLIN PROGRAM AND ACCOUNTING
AND AS PART OF OUR MEDICAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEMS-
WOULD- INCREASE THE- S. MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES THAT ARE.
PROVIDED TO THIS POPULATION WITH
A PARTICULAR EMPHASIS ON
INTEGRATING SERVICES BETWEEN
PHYSICAL HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH
AND STD TREATMENT- SOMETHING
THAT HAS BECOME VERYAPPARENT TO
US. NOT ONLY IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY HOMELESS WHAT TIME COUNT
OF WHICH NEARLY FORTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
RIGHT GONNA FIGHT IS HAVING A
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS. BUT ALSO
. UP AN ASSESSMENT THAT WE JUST
SPENT A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TIME PULLING TOGETHER OF WHICH
ONE OF THE MOST CRITICAL
IDENTIFIED NEEDS WAS A UTE. A
HOUSING OPTIONS AND COMMUNITY
PLACEMENTS FOR PEOPLE WITH
SERIOUS AND PERSISTENT MENTAL
ILLNESS- THE GREAT HOUSING FUNDS
WOULD BE AVAILABLE. FOR THE
COURSE OF FIVE YEARS FUNDS WE
INTEND TO MAKE AVAILABLE-
STARTING AS SOON AS JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE- I HATE I'M
MORE THAN HAPPY TO TAKE A
QUESTION SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THIS
OR- I HOPE THAT THAT. UPS IN
LIGHT AND- I RECOGNIZE THAT
THESE ARE REALLY REALLY HIGH
NEED HIGH RISK POPULATIONS AND-
WHILE THERE ARE ROVIDERS OUT
THERE OFTENTIMES THEY NEED SOME
ADDITIONAL PATCH FUNDING IN
ORDER TO HAVE EITHER THE LOW
STAFF RATIOS OR THE ADDITIONAL
STAFFING OR THE ADDITIONAL
SERVICES- TRANSPORTATION- FOOD
SHELTER- THAT WOULD BE NECESSARY
TO WORK WITH THIS POPULATION.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
RESPONSE I THINK- A LOT OF US OR
SEEN THE GROWTH OF ENCAMPMENTS
AND WE WANT TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO
WE ENSURE THAT WE ARE HELPING
THOSE IN NEED AND ALSO PROVIDING
THE SERVICES MENTAL HEALTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE
ABUSE ETCETERA. THAT FOLKS NEED
SO THAT- WE CAN ENSURE THAT
THERE'S- THAT THEY'RE RECEIVING
RESOURCES WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
APPLYING- THE NECESSARY. THE
NECESSARY PRESSURES TO ENSURE
THAT OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES ARE
ALSO DOING THAT WORK AND WE'RE
NOT SEEN A GROWTH OF
ENCAMPMENTS. SO WHICH IS WHY THE
QUESTION ON WHEN THAT REPORT IS
GOING TO BE AVAILABLE OF ON THE
MEASUREMENTS OF SUCCESS. FROM A
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
ALLOCATION TO A FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
ALLOCATION. IS ACTUALLY QUITE
CRITICAL. WE DON'T HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
WERE GOING TO MOVE ON THANK YOU
SO MUCH TO OUR- PANEL NUMBER
EIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER NINE DEVELOPMENT
AND COMPLIANCE. SECTIONS
WORKLOAD MS ROPELESS IF YOU'RE
ON PLEASE BEGIN. HI THINKING
MEDICARE AND MEMBERS TIME NANCY
ROBUST WITH THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE. SO THE
REQUEST BEFORE YOU TWO DAYS A
PROPOSAL FOR ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION FOUR EIGHT NEW STAFF
MEMBERS THREE IN OUR DEVELOPMENT
SECTION- A RESEARCH DEVELOPMENT
SPECIALIST AND FOR COMPLIANCE
STAFF. CALIFORNIA IS THE LARGEST
USER OF THE LOW INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDIT PROGRAM IN THE NATION
AND ALL OF THESE POSITIONS
REQUESTED WILL SUPPORT PRIVATE
INVESTMENT TO FURTHER DEVELOP
AND PRESERVE- MUCH NEEDED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA. IN THE PAST FEW
YEARS TAX CREDITS HAVE HELPED TO
DEVELOP PRODUCE OVER A TWENTY
THOUSAND NEW CONSTRUCTION
AFFORDABLE UNITS EACH YEAR. FOR
OUR DEVELOPMENT STAFF- THOSE ARE
NEEDED TO KEEP UP WITH THE
INFLUX OF TAX CREDIT
APPLICATIONS. THE DEMAND FAR
EXCEEDS OUR AVAILABILITY AND ITS
LEAVES- IT LEAVES THE PROGRAM
OVER SUBSCRIBED YEAR OVER YEAR.
WHERE IS HE RECEIVING
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
APPLICATIONS A YEAR. AND WE'RE
ONLY ABLE TO AWARD ABOUT ONE
THIRD OF. INSTANCE TAX CREDITS
HAVE BECOME COMPETITIVE THE
NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS HAVE
INCREASED AND THE COMPLEXITY OF
THE ANALYSIS REQUIRED AND THE
LENGTH OF TIME THAT THOSE
APPLICATIONS HAS INCREASED AS
WELL. AND WE'VE HAD ABOUT A 30%
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
APPLICATIONS THAT WE'VE BEEN
REVIEWING SENSE ABOUT TWENTY
TWENTY. DEVELOPMENT STAFFER
RESPONSIBLE TO CONDUCT THREE
LEVELS OF REVIEW- PROJECTS
THROUGH THE DEVELOPMENT STAGE
AND THOSE ARE- HIGHER S.
REQUIREMENTS. WE HAVE THE
APPLICATION REVIEW THE READY
NEXT YEAR PROCEED RUBIO AND ALSO
REPLACEMENT SERVICE REVIEW THESE
FEDERAL MANDATES DO NOT AFFORD
US THE OPPORTUNITY TO FALL
BEHIND YET WE HAVE. WE'RE
DESPERATELY TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR STATE AGENCY IS NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR HOLDING UP
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS.
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE STAFF
TO PERFORM THE MANDATED
REQUIREMENTS NECESSARY TO ALLOW
HOUSING DEVELOPERS TO PROCEED.
I'M ANOTHER TASK THAT- DIDN'T
EXIST BEFORE HAS RECENTLY
SERVICE- YEARS AGO. T. CAC
COMMITTEE- WE COMMITTED TO DOING
A SUBSIDY LAYERING REVIEWS FOR
HUD ON TAX CREDIT PROJECTS AND
SINCE WE'RE THE ONLY STATE
ENTITY THAT POSSESSES ITS
EXPERTISE WE'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED
TO PERFORM THIS TASK ON NON TAX
CREDIT PROJECTS RECENTLY WE'VE
BEEN RECEIVING THESE REQUESTS
AND ANTICIPATE INCREASING NUMBER
OF THOSE. AS DEVELOPERS ARE
USING OTHER FUNDS THAT HAVE THIS
REQUIREMENT WHEN THEY'RE UNABLE
TO OBTAIN TAX CREDITS. WE'VE
ALSO BEEN ASSIGNED A NEW TASK
THROUGH THE BUDGET ACTIVE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO WORK WITH THE
OFFICE OF HISTORIC PRESERVATION
TO IMPLEMENT A NEW PROGRAM TO
ALLOCATE TAX CREDITS FOR THE
REHABILITATION OF HISTORIC
BUILDINGS. WERE ALSO- PRESENTLY
UTILIZING EXISTING STAFF TO
DEVELOP AND RUN THAT PROGRAM
TAKING THEM AWAY FROM THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COSTS. I
DELETE MUCH OF THIS WORK WOULD
BE DONE BY A RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT ANALYSTS WHICH IS
ONE OF THE POSITIONS THAT WERE
REQUESTING TODAY. IN ADDITION TO
THE RT EIGHT IT ALSO COORDINATES
THE MULTIPLE NUMBER OF. THE
REPORT. WITHIN OUR COMPLIANCE
DIVISION- ARE A COMPRESSIONAL
MANDATE REQUIRES THAT T. CAP BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING THAT
EVERY TAX CREDIT PROJECT IN
CALIFORNIA IS MONITORED EVERY
THREE YEARS FOR A TERM OF FIFTY
FIVE YEARS. THIS MODERN
MONITORING MUST BE CONDUCTED ON
SITE AND INCLUDES BOTH PHYSICAL
INSPECTION AND FILE REVIEWS.
MCCARTY CATHCART FOLIO CONSIST
OF ALMOST FIVE THOUSAND PROJECTS
AND WITH THE INCREASED NUMBER
OF. PROJECTS GROWING BY
APPROXIMATELY. TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
TO THREE HUNDRED THREE HUNDRED
PROJECTS ANNUALLY T. CAP IS NOT
ADEQUATELY STAFF TO MEET THE
FEDERALLY MANDATED MODERN. YEAH
IN JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY. THE
IRS. HI QUITE A COMPLIANCE
MONITORING REGULATION THAT
GREATLY INCREASED OUR COMPLIANCE
WORKLOAD THE REGULATIONS REQUIRE
THIS THAT STATES CONDUCT
PHYSICAL INSPECTIONS OF EVERY
PROPERTY EVERY THREE YEARS FOR
FIFTY FIVE YEARS WITH NEW
REQUIREMENTS TO IMPOSE MORE
RIGOROUS PHYSICAL INSPECTION OF
THE PROPERTY INSPECTIONS MUST
INCLUDE A PHYSICAL INSPECTION OF
ALL BUILDING EXTERIORS AND
COMMON PLACES AND BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF EXISTING UNITS ON THE
INCREASING PROJECTS. UP WE MIGHT
BE REQUIRED TO INSPECT AS MANY
AS. SEVENTEEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
PROJECTS THAT YEAR. IN ADDITION
COMPLIANCE CONDUCTS HUNDREDS OF
HOURS OF TRAINING THOUSANDS OF
STAKEHOLDERS EVERY YEAR ANY
ANSWERS OVER THREE THOUSAND
PHONE CALLS AND EMAILS FROM
STAKEHOLDERS AND TENANTS. AND
THEN THEY CONDUCT RESEARCH AND
FOLLOW UP WITH TENANT COMPLAINTS
. THE MORE HOUSING UNITS WOULD
REDUCE THE MORE THESE IMPORTANT
TASKS INCREASE AND WE MUST
INCREASE OUR STAFF. AND
PROPORTIONATELY TO THE RATE AT
THE INCREASING PROJECTS. I'D
LIKE TO ADD THAT SINCE THE CITY
WAS WRITTEN AND SUBMITTED TO YOU
THE NINETEEN VACANCIES LISTED
ARE NOW ONLY A LOT WE'VE HIRED
NINE NEW STAFF AND WE LOST ONE
THAT'S THE- END OF LAST YEAR AND
THEN FIVE OF THE ELEVEN STAFF
ARE IN THE COMPLIANCE
DEPARTMENT. THREE YEAR IN THE
DEVELOPMENT UNIT AND THE OTHERS
ARE ADMINISTRATIVE. THE
DIFFICULTY THAT WE HAD HIRING
THOSE STAFF WAS DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC NINETEEN AT COBIT
NINETEEN HAD THAT MAKE. AND THE
FACT THAT THE COMPLAINTS TO THE
STATEMENT HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL
TRAVEL REQUIREMENTS IMBEDDED
WITHIN THEM. AND DOES THIS
HINDERED A LOT OF PEOPLE FOR
APPLYING FOR THE POSITIONS AND
THEN WHEN DISCOVERING THAT THERE
WAS SO MUCH TRAVEL INVOLVED NOT
WANTING TO TAKE THOSE POSITIONS-
WE JUST RECENTLY LEAVE
SUCCESSFULLY HIRED FIVE. NEW
STAFF MEMBERS- FOR COMPLIANCE-
POSITION SO WE'RE STARTING TO
UNDERSTAND THAT PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
COMFORTABLE- TRAVELING RIGHT NOW
. SO I THINK THE COMMITTEE FOR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU CAN YOU
PERCENT ON ISSUE NUMBER TEN
PLEASE AND THEN WE'LL GO TO THE
ALLEY- IN FINANCE FOR BOTH AND
THEN COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE MEMBERS AND I ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE. KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
BRIEF. I'M CERTAINLY. SO FOR US
IT LACKED THE CALIFORNIA GOT
LIMIT ALLOCATION COMMITTEE OUT
WE ALLOCATE THE STATE'S VOLUME
CAP FOR TAXEXEMPT BONDS. AND
THE AMOUNT THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
IS FOUR POINT THREE BILLION WERE
REQUESTING- ONE MILLION THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND. FOR SIX STAFF
MEMBERS. AND LIKE TO CAC VERY
SIMILARLY WE HAVE- YOU KNOW A
HUGE INFLUX OF APPLICATIONS IT'S
CONTINUALLY INCREASING AND ALONG
WITH OUR- OUR- HAVE REGULATION
CHANGES- IT REQUIRES A LOT MORE
TRAINING AND- A LOT MORE
DILIGENCE WITH THE APPLICATIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M GONNA
GO TO THE DEPARTMENT I'M SORRY
TO THE L. A. O. BOTH ON ISSUE
NUMBER NINE AND TEN AND THEN
FOLLOWED BY FINANCE. THANK YOU
THIS MORALES WITH THE L. A. O.
I'M NO COMMENTS FOR EITHER THE
PROPOSALS. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. TWENTY CHEN DEPARTMENT
FINANCED WELL WE HAVE NOTHING TO
ADD AND HAPPY TO AVAILABLE TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN.
I'M SORRY ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
LADIES WE'RE GOING TO GO ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN FULL SCALE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CAL
SAVER'S RETIREMENT SAVINGS
PROGRAM MISS ASSELIN SCARE YOU
ON IT SO PLEASE- BEGIN. YES
MADAM CHAIR I AM HERE CAN YOU
HEAR AND SEE ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU
THE VIDEO MAY BE A LITTLE BIT ON
DELAY PLEASE BEGIN. OKAY THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS AND KATIE SALEN SKATE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALPERS RETIREMENT SAVINGS
BOARD. AND BY WAY OF REMINDER
CAL SAVERS IS FOR PRIVATE SECTOR
WORKERS WHO LACK ACCESS TO A
RETIREMENT PLAN AT WORK. IT'S
VOLUNTARY FOR EMPLOYEES BUT IS
OPERATED ON AN AUTOMATIC
ENROLMENT OPT OUT BASIS. AND THE
LAWS DOUBLES AND HEALTHY BIRTH
COMES OF THE REQUIREMENT IN
PLAYERS THAT HAVE AT LEAST FIVE
EMPLOYEES AND DO NOT OFFER A
RETIREMENT PLAN MUST FACILITATE
ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE WORSE FOR
THEIR EMPLOYEESOR FACE
PENALTIES. AT THIS PROPOSAL
REQUESTS SIX MILLION DOLLARS AN
ADDITIONAL LOAN AUTHORITY AND
THREE NEW POSITIONS TO CONTINUE
OPERATING THE CUSTOMER'S PROGRAM
FOR APPROXIMATELY THE NEXT THREE
FISCAL YEARS AND ALSO SPENT
ABOUT TWO OR THREE MINUTES TO
PROVIDE YOU AN UPDATE. EARLY
PROGRESS TO DATE I CALPERS
LAUNCHED AND BEGAN ITS THREE
YEAR ROLLOUT IN JULY TWENTY
NINETEEN JUST ABOUT SIX MONTHS
BEFORE THE ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC
AND WITHIN THIS THREE YEAR
ROLLOUT WE HAVE THREE. STAGGERED
IMPLANT EMPLOYER COMPLIANCE
DEADLINES WHICH VARY BY SIZE AND
WE ARE APPROACHING RIGHT NOW THE
FINAL EMPLOYER COMPLIANCE
DEADLINE IN FOUR MONTHS ON JUNE
THIRTIETH FOR THE SMALLEST
EMPLOYERS. AND VERY IMPORTANT TO
KNOW YOUR VERY RELEVANT FOR THIS
AT B. C. P. AS THAT THE FINAL
DEADLINE APPLIES TO MORE THAN
90% OF THE TOTAL. ESTIMATED
EMPLOYER VOLUME OF TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN THOUSAND EMPLOYERS
AND THAT MEANS THAT WE ARE
FACING A MASSIVE SURGE OF
EMPLOYERS RIGHT NOW. YOU KNOW
ALL OF THOSE WHOM HAVE QUESTIONS
AND REQUIRE SUPPORT AND THE
MAJORITY OF THAT SUPPORT IS
PROVIDED BY OUR CURRENT
CONTRACTED PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATOR- BUT A PORTION OF
THE BILL YOU HAVE TO COME TO OUR
STAFF A RESOLUTION IN SUPPORT
AND- WE HAVE LEARNED A LOT IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS ABOUT
HOW- HOW THOSE CASES AND
REFERRALS BREAKDOWN. AND TO DATE
WE HAV THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
EMPLOYERS HAVE REGISTERED ACROSS
THE STATE ALMOST ONE THIRD OF
COMMON. JOINED IN THE LAST TWO
MONTHS AND THAT LEAVES US WITH
ONE HUNDRED NINETY THREE
THOUSAND EMPLOYERS. OF THE
REMAIN FIRST ENGAGED WHAT THIS
YEAR. AND REGARDING FAVOR STUFF
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF OUR PROCESS
RATE OF. PERCENT AMONG ALL
ELIGIBLE EMPLOYEE IS AND THAT'S
REMAINED. CONSISTENT SINCE OUR
LAUNCH AND IF IT GETS REALLY
MEANINGFUL WHEN WE CONSIDER THAT
THE MEDIAN INCOME OF THE
POPULATION IS LESS THAN THIRTY
THOUSAND. DOLLARS PER YEAR AND
THEY DON'T RECEIVE ANY. THAT AN
EMPLOYER MATCH OR GOVERNMENT
CONTRIBUTIONS OTHERS MAKING THAT
WORK- IN THEIR HOUSEHOLD BUDGETS
. AND WE HAVE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND FUNDED
ACCOUNTS HOLDING ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
ASSETS AS OF RIGHT NOW. AND
SAVERS ARE CONTRIBUTING ABOUT
EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS A
MONTH- I WILL NOTE AT THIS
STATISTIC IT IS IT'S VERY
NOTABLE THAT MORE THAN 38% OF
OUR SABERS RIGHT NOW HAVE
CONTRIBUTED VM. MORE THAN ONE
JOB WHICH REFLECTS THAT THE
PORTABILITY OF THE PROGRAM IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND IS WORKING
AS DESIGNED- AN UPDATE ON
ENFORCEMENT QUICKLY WE DELAYED
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF PENALTIES
FOR EMPLOYERS NONCOMPLIANCE
DURING THE FIRST. NEARLY TWO
YEARS OF THE PANDEMIC BUT I'VE
RECENTLY BEGUN. VERY QUICKLY I
HAD TO IMPOSE PENALTIES FOR THE
LARGEST NON COMPLIANT EMPLOYERS
WHOSE DEADLINE WAS SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY WHICH IN ITSELF
WAS EXTENDED FROM JUNE TO CO
THAT I THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
IS OUR PARTNER IN ACHIEVING
THOSE PENALTIES AND- YOU KNOW IT
ONE OF THE DIFFICULT THINK
THANKS TO PROJECT. TO PROJECT
HERE IS THE EFFECTIVE OF
ENFORCEMENT THAT REMAINS TO BE
SEEN BUT WE REALLY ARE
OPTIMISTIC THAT IT WILL HELP US
BRING THESE EMPLOYERS INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THEIR EMPLOYEES
HAVE ACCESS. I HAVE THE ACCESS
TO CAL SAVERS THAT A LOT
PROMISES AND YOU KNOW IN CLOSING
ON TO SAY THAT WE ARE GROWING
VERY QUICKLY AND THIS ADDITIONAL
LOAN AUTHORITY I WILL ALLOW US
TO CONTINUE OPERATIONS THROUGH
THE ROLL OUT AND THAT REALLY
GROWTH YEARS. WHILE WE BUILD
TOWARDS SELF SUFFICIENCY AND
MEDICARE THAT'S ALL I HAVE HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THANK. YOU
SO MUCH WILL GO TO THE L. A-
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON ALTHOUGH
WITH ALLEGED WAS OFF ARE IS NO.
WITH THAT THE GENERAL FOR THE
PURPOSE HAVE WORK WITH. ON HELP
US IN ANY WAY ON BOTH QUESTIONS
SIX. THANK YOU TO PARA FINANCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ILLICITLY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE HAVE
NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS TIME BUT
ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU ANY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MISTER
NAZARIAN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION I JUST WANTED TO-
YOU RATTLED OFF A FEW NUMBERS
AND I ONLY CAUGHT THE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY TWO MILLION SO DO YOU
MIND ALSO GOING GOING BACK AGAIN
AND SAY HOW MANY PARTICIPANTS
YOU HAVE AND WHAT THE AVERAGE
SAVINGS IS- AND IT IS THAT I GET
THE RIGHT NUMBER OF THE TOTAL
ASSETS BEING AT A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY TWO MILLION. YES SIR
HAPPY TO GO BACK IT IS A TOTAL
ASSETS ARE HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO
MILLION. AND THAT IS ACROSS TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX THOUSAND
FUNDED ACCOUNTS. ARE AVERAGE
FUNDED ACCOUNT BALANCE IS SEVEN
HUNDRED SEVENTY DOLLARS RIGHT
NOW. I WILL NOTE THAT THAT AND
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE WHILE WE'RE
GROWING AND SURGING THE
DENOMINATOR THERE ADD GROWS SO
THAT BRINGS HER BRINGS DOWN OUR
AVERAGE WE DO HAVE- AT SEVERAL
YOU KNOW SOME OF OUR MORE MATURE
ACCOUNTS HAVE. OVER TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS ACCOUNT BALANCE AND SO
THERE'S A REAL DISTRIBUTION OF
THOSE ACROSS SIZE DEPENDING ON
THE MATURITY OF THE ACCOUNT. N.
HOW MANY OF THESE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND ACCOUNTS ARE
IN THE SAME HOUSEHOLD- I WOULD
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT
AND I'M NOT. THAT MIGHT BE A
LITTLE DIFFICULT TO GET BUT WE
CAN WE CAN SEE WHAT WE CAN GET
FOR YOU. OKAY AND WHERE DO YOU
SEE THE WEIGHT OF THESE ACCOUNTS
COMING IN. WHICH COUNTIES ARE
THE HIGHEST PRODUCING. AND BY
THE WAY YOU YOU CAN GET BACK TO
ME ABOUT THESE LATER ON I'D LOVE
TO JUST TALK TO YOU A LITTLE BIT
MORE I WOULD I JUST WANT TO GET
A SENSE OF WHAT YOUR PROJECTED
INCREASES IS WHAT THE GOALS THE
BENCHMARKS ARE OF WHAT NUMBER OF
ACCOUNTS YOU WANT TO HAVE
OPENED- YEAR OVER YEAR AND WHERE
DO YOU NEED TO BE SO I'D LIKE
TO. DELVE INTO THAT A LITTLE BIT
MORE. YES THOSE ARE GREAT
QUESTIONS THAT I WE SPENT A LOT
OF TIME THINKING ABOUT THE VERY
FAIR. ON THE COUNTY DISTRIBUTION
IT ROUGHLY REFLECTS OUR
POPULATION. SO WE ARE NOT SEEING
ANYTHING UNUSUAL OR SURPRISING
ABOUT THE DISTRIBUTION OF
ACCOUNTS ACROSS. ALL THE COUNTY
IS IT REALLY JUST REFLECTS A
POPULATION AT THIS POINT. YOU
KNOW WHAT WE DO SPEND A LOT OF
TIME LOOKING AT AS INDUSTRY.
OBVIOUSLY- WORKERS WHO LACK
ACCESS TO A WORK A WORKPLACE
BASED RETIREMENT PLAN ARE OVER
REPRESENTED IN RETAIL RESTAURANT
HOTEL ACCOMMODATIONS
AGRICULTURE- THOSE ARE SOME OF
HER. WASTE MANAGEMENT THOSE ARE
SOME OF OUR BIGGEST- INDUSTRIES.
AND ADAM WHAT I CAN DO ABOUT IT
ENGAGE FURTHER ON ALL OF THIS- I
CAN SEND YOU OUR- ANNUAL REPORT
FROM LAST YEAR WHICH- ANSWER
SOME OF THESE QUESTIONS. BUT IN
TERMS OF YOUR- HE MENTIONED THAT
YOU'RE- INTERESTED IN AND
PROJECTIONS. IT'S AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
PREDICT BOTH EMPLOYER BEHAVIOR
AND THEIR COMPLIANCE- A LOT OF
THAT IS GOING TO BE HANDS ON THE
EFFECT OF THIS PENALTY
IMPOSITION. AND UNTIL WE GET THE
EMPLOYER'S COMPLAINT WE HAVE NO
ACCESS TO THE THAT TO THE WORK
FORCE SO. THAT'S ONE OF THE
DIFFICULT THINGS TO PROJECT ALSO
DIFFICULT TO PREDICT WHAT YOU
KNOW WHAT HUMAN BEHAVIOR WILL
DEAL WITH THAT YOU KNOW EMPLOYEE
BEHAVIOR WILL BE. BUT IN IN
TERMS I HAVE BASED ON. AND A SET
OF ASSUMPTIONS THAT WE HAVE IT
IT'S IF WE LOOK FIVE YEARS AFTER
FROM RIGHT NOW WE'RE LOOKING AT-
I'M SOMEWHERE IN THE RANGE OF
500-100-0800 THOUSAND FUNDED
ACCOUNTS. OF COURSE. THAT'S
BASED ON ASSUMPTIONS THAT CAN
CHANGE AND- I KNOW IT'S GOING TO
COME OUT OF MY MOUTH IT'S WRONG
BUT ON THE BUT THAT'S- SORT OF
OUR BEST ESTIMATE AT THIS POINT
AND THAT'S A BIG RANGE. AND I'M
FAVORITE ASSETS WE'RE LOOKING AT
AGAIN FIVE YEARS OUT SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN TWO AND A HALF BILLION
AND FIVE BILLION IN ASSETS.
OBVIOUSLY ON THE ASSET SIDE IT
DEPENDS ON THE ABILITY OF THE
WORK FORCE TO PEOPLE ROLL THEIR
FUNDS OUT IF THEY- GET A NEW JOB
ALSO OBVIOUSLY INVESTMENT
RETURNS. BUT I'M AS OF RIGHT NOW
THAT'S ARE ARE. THOSE ARE PATH
THAT'S A PREDICTIONS ON WHERE
WILL BE OUTSIDE YOURSELF. THANKS
TO REQUEST TWO MORE QUICK
QUESTIONS INDUSTRY SECTORS THAT
YOU'RE SEEING A- PREVALENT OR
INDUSTRY SECTORS THAT ARE. USING
GREATER ACTIVITY. IN OPENING
THESE ACCOUNTS OR. OR NOT
NECESSARILY. YES S. I THINK.
RETAIL REST- HOTEL. AGRICULTURE
WASTE MANAGEMENT THOSE ARE SOME
OF THE- MOST HEAVILY REPRESENTED
AND THAT REALLY REFLECTS- THE
LACK OF ACCESS TO A WORKPLACE
BIGGEST PLAN INDIA PERCENTAGE
BREAKDOWNS FOR THESE. WOULD YOU
BE ABLE TO GROW ITS IN OUR
ANNUAL REPORT I'M AND I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO GET BACK TO YOU RIGHT
AWAY GREAT THANK YOU AND THEN.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST MARKETING.
WHAT YES MY GOSH. WHAT WHAT'S
WHAT'S BEEN YOUR BUDGET ON
MARKETING. SO OUR MARKETING. WE
DO A LARGE PORTION OF OUR
MARKETING THROUGH OUR PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATOR ARE CONTRACTED
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATOR BY STATUTE
WE OPERATE- SORT OF IN A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PART. PARTNERSHIP MODEL
AND OUR OUR BUSINESS PARTNER
SENSES HAS COMMITTED AN ANNUAL
DOLLAR AMOUNT TOWARDS A MARKET
TO BOTH EMPLOYERS AND SAVERS-
AND THAT YOU KNOW COVERS A RANGE
OF THINGS INCLUDING THE WEBSITE
WEBINARS. THAT DIRECT MAIL THAT
WE SEND TO EMPLOYERS AND FAVORS-
DIGITAL- DIGITAL MARKETING WHAT
IT DOES NOT COVER- AND THAT'S
ABOUT TWO MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
THAT THEY'VE COMMITTED WHAT THAT
DOES NOT COVER IS NON DIGITAL
ADVERTISING WHICH IS PART OF
THIS IBCP REQUEST WERE
INTERESTED IN- OPERATING AN
EXPERIMENT ON OUT OF HOME
ADVERTISING AND BUT WHAT THAT
MEANS IS. TRANSIT ADS BUS STOPS
OUTSIDE THE BUSES- ADVERTISING
ON THE SIDES OF BUILDINGS- SO
THAT WE CAN RAISE AWARENESS
BECAUSE YOU KNOW DOING TRYING TO
GET THE WORD OUT TO YOU KNOW
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND EMPLOYERS
AND TO THEIR MILLIONS OF WORKERS
ABOUT THE EXISTENCE OF
HEALTHCARE IS. REALLY DIFFICULT
TO DO ON A SHOESTRING BUDGET SO
THE VAST MAJORITY OF WHAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DO SO FAR HAS BEEN
THROUGH OUR PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATOR ON THEIR AT THEIR
COMMITMENT TO MARKETING WE HAVE
A COUPLE OF STAFF WHO ARE
DEDICATED TO OUR REGION
EDUCATION HERE. BUT WHAT WE'RE
FINDING IS IT'S REALLY IT'S
REALLY NOT QUITE ENOUGH IN A LOT
OF THEIR TIME IS BEING OCCUPIED
WITH ESSENTIALLY CUSTOMER
SERVICE- ENGAGEMENT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN AND
THANK YOU TO- THANK YOU TO ALL
THE PANELISTS THAT THINKING
MESSALONSKEE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE.
ACTUALLY WE'RE GOING TO DO ISSUE
NUMBER TWELVE AND THIRTEEN
COMBINED MR MILLER THAT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING IF
YOU CAN PLEASE KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS BRIEF. LET'S BEGIN. I
WILL GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRMAN AND CHIEF OPEN AT
NUMBERS HI MICHAEL- DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES THE DEPARTMENT AIRPLANE
AND HOUSING. OUR FIRST PROPOSAL
ADDRESSES THE DEPARTMENTS RISING
ADMINISTRATIVE WORKLOADS
INCLUDING APPEALS PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT REQUEST WE'VE GOT A REACHED
CONTRACTS AND PROCUREMENT AND
ACCOUNTING PRACTICES AND
PERSISTENCE OF MINISTERING A
STATEWIDE HATE CRIME HOTLINE.
APPROVED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT. DLPH HAS
EXPANDED SIGNIFICANTLY IN THE
PAST TWO FISCAL YEARS THIS
REQUEST WOULD HELP INCREASE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT TO ASSIST.
JOINING ME TODAY IS MAYBE WE DO
HAVE EACH DEPUTY DIRECTOR. AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO HELP ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY. THANK YOU CAN
YOU ALSO SPEAK ON ISSUE THIRTEEN
. ABSOLUTELY OUR SECOND PROPOSAL
ADDRESSES A RESOURCE REQUEST TO
ENFORCE GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION
ONE TWO NINE NINE NINE UNDER SB
NINE SEVENTY THREE WHICH
REQUIRES EMPLOYERS OF ONE
HUNDRED OR MORE EMPLOYEES WITH
EVEN ONE EMPLOYEE IN CALIFORNIA
TO REPORT PAY AND HOURS WORKED
DATA BY STAFF WHICH MEANT. JOB
CATEGORY SEX RACE AND ETHNICITY
TO THE DEPARTMENT CONTINUALLY IN
ORDER TO STRENGTHEN EQUAL PAY
LAWS AND CLOSE THE GENDER PAY
GAP. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE DO
HAVE EACH SUCCESSFULLY LAUNCHED
CLOSE THE CREATED A PORTAL ON
TIME WITH PERSONAL CONTRACTING
RESOURCES APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE WE CONTINUE TO
PURSUE THOSE EMPLOYERS WHO FAIL
TO RESPOND TO THE FIRST YEARS
REPORTING DEADLINE. AND TO
ANALYZE THE DATA IN ORDER TO
POST HER FIRST ANNUAL REPORT FOR
PUBLIC CONSUMPTION. YES EACH
OPEN THE PORTAL FOR THE SECOND
YEAR OF REPORTING JUST LAST
MONTH ON FEBRUARY FIRST RESOURCE
REQUEST UNDER CONSIDERATION
TODAY WOULD EXPAND THE
DEPARTMENT'S ABILITY TO PERFORM
STATISTICAL ANALYSIS OF
AGGREGATED PKT. I'M SORRY PAY
BAND DATA THROUGH BOTH OF
COLUMBUS IN A RESEARCH SCIENTIST
RECRUITED DIGITAL FORENSICS
SPECIALIST TO ENSURE THE DATA
RECEIVED IS STORED TRANSFERRED
AND USED SECURELY WHILE
REMAINING ACCESSIBLE TO DETER
FUTURE ATTORNEYS FOR WHAT
OCCASION PURPOSES. AND WE'RE
HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS IF YOU
HAVE. THANK YOU GO TO THE TO.
I'M SORRY TO THE L. A. O. AND
THEN THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
BILLS THAN THEY SHOULD TWELVE
AND THIRTEEN PLACE. YOU WERE THE
FINALISTS WITH THE L. A. O. NO
ISSUES TO RAISE WITH EITHER OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING PROPOSALS.
THANK YOU. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
CHRIS COOK WITH APARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO FURTHER COMMENTS ON
EITHER ISSUE BUT AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU ANY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. CENA THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN. IS THE
DEPUTY COMMISSIONER ON THE LINE
AND IF SO- MS BARNHART PLEASE
START. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM AT THE
BARN HEART TO BE COMMISSIONER OF
MINISTRATION OF THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION. OUR FIRST B. FIFTY
FINANCIAL ABUSE OF ELDERS ORD'S
PENDANT ADULTS WORKLOAD- IT'S
ABOUT THE LEGISLATURE EXPANDED
THE CATEGORY OF MANDATED
REPORTERS. OF SUSPECTED
FINANCIAL CREWS TO INCLUDE
BROKER DEALERS AND INVESTMENT
ADVISERS IN SENATE BILL FOUR
NINETY SIX IN JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY. ADDITIONALLY BROKER
DEALERS AND INVESTMENT ADVISERS
LICENSEES MUST FILE REPORTS ON
SUSPECTED FINANCIAL ABUSE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT. IN OCTOBER.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE EIGHTY SIX
THIRTY SIX AUTHORIZED
INFORMATION RELEVANT TO THE
INCIDENT OF ELDER OR DEPENDENT
ADULT ABUSE TO BE GIVEN TO
FEDERAL LAW MONEY TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. WHAT'S SO
PURPOSE OF INVESTIGATIVE
RELATING RELATED CRIMES AND
AUTHORIZED INFORMATION TO BE
GIVEN TO LOCAL CODE ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY. TO INVESTIGATE AN
UNLICENSED CARE FACILITIES ONE
IN ELDER OR DEPENDENT PERSON IS
AT RISK. SHARE THIS INFORMATION
REQUIRES ADDITIONAL TIME FOR
DEPARTMENT STAFF TO COORDINATE
COLLABORATE. WITH THESE OUTSIDE
AGENCY. THANK OF RAPE A FEW FILE
AS A FROM HUNDRED AND LAST YEAR
TWO EIGHT HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. ANY DELAY IN
PROCESSING THESE REPORTS CAN
CAUSE A DELAY IN DISBURSEMENT OF
FUNDS WHICH CAN NEGATIVELY
IMPACT THE CONSUMER WHO MAY HAVE
A VALID REASON TO NEED THE
MONEY. THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDES
TWO POSITIONS AND FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE FIVE THOUSAND IN THE
FIRST YEAR AND FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY THOUSAND ON GOING TO
MANAGE THIS ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD.
WITH ME TODAY IS BABCOCK DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER BROKER DEALERS AND
INVESTMENT ADVISERS WE ARE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE. THANK YOU FOR THAT LET'S
GO TO THE L. L. PLEASE. HERE'S
WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THESE. HONG
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS FURTHER OF THE ISSUES
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU ANY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. K. SEEN NONE
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE GOING TO
GO ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN-
DEPUTY COMMISSIONER IF YOU CAN
BEGIN. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS IS ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC BANKING OPTION ACT. AND
THE WORKLOAD WE SEE WITHIN OUR
DEPARTMENT AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
SEVEN ESTABLISH THE CALC HELP
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION WHICH IS
TASKED FOR COMPLETING A MARKET
ANALYSIS. ON THE CALCULUS WILL
GRAHAM THIS PROGRAM WOULD
PROVIDE CALIFORNIANS WITH A NUKE
NO COST CHECKING ACCOUNT. THIS
YEAR YEAH I COMMISSIONER AND
THEIR DESIGNEES WILL HAVE TO
SPEND CONSIDERABLE TIME ON THE
COMMISSION AN IMPORTANT MEETING
. THE DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING
ONE POSITION AND TWO YEARS OF
FUNDING TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE
THOUSAND IN THE FIRST YEAR AND
200-700-0070 THREE THOUSAND THE
SECOND. SO THAT THE DEPARTMENT
WILL BE ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY
PARTICIPATE IN THE STUDY UNDER
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN. WITH ME
TODAY IS NOW CALLED THE STOP IS
TO TELL ME DEPUTY COMMISSIONER
OF LEGISLATION WE ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE. THANK YOU L. L. NO
CONCERNS MADAM CHAIR DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. NO SEEING NONE I JUST
HAVE ONE QUICK QUESTION CAN DE
FPI DISCUSS MINE ATTORNEY IS
NEEDED TO FULFILL THE
REQUIREMENTS OF AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN. AND REMEMBER-
MANY MISS MCCALL HE SAID TO ME
AND I COULD SPEAK TO THAT.
STATUTE REQUIRES THE COMMISSION
TO CONSTRUCT OFFENDER'S CONDUCT
MARKET ANALYSIS HOLD  PUBLIC
HEARING WILL BE THE ANALYSIS AND
MAKE DETERMINATIONS. WHEN THE
BILL IS MOVING THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE IT WAS CONVEYED TO
US THAT THE DF YEAH I WOULD BE
IN A VERY IMPORTANT MEMBER OF
THE COMMISSION. STARTING THE
COMMISSION FROM A STATE
REGULATORY POINT OF VIEW.
UTILIZED EXPERTISE TO HELP
CREATE THE MARKET ANALYSIS
CONTRACTED TO GUIDE UNDER ONE
COMPLETING THE ANALYSIS USING
WHAT I HAVE SEEN OUR BANKING AND
REGULATORY EXPERIENCE. WELL THE
STAFF IT REQUIRES THE
COMMISSIONER OR HER DOES IT NEED
TO ATTEND THE MEETINGS BEING AN
ACTIVE AND USEFUL COMMISSION
UNDERCOVER FIRE ADDITIONAL WORK.
OTHER THAN JUST AND IN THE SEATS
WE BELIEVE IT'S REQUESTED
POSITION WILL NOT ONLY ACT AS
THE COMMISSIONERS DESIGNATE WHEN
NEEDED BUT WILL ALSO CREEK AND
PROVIDED CHEERIOS AND
PREPARATION FOR THE MEETING.
ENGAGE WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
GATHER AND CONSOLIDATE DATA AND
INFORMATION FROM BOTH INSIDE THE
DEPARTMENT AND OUTSIDE
STAKEHOLDERS AND EXPERTS
RESEARCH A WEAK LITTLE POLICY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMISSIONER
ASSIST WITH CREATIVE MONITORING
THE. CONTRACT AND REVEALING THE
FINAL REPORT. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THAT RIGHT. I WOULD
KNOW WHAT COMMENTS ARE. WE WILL
WRAP UP THANK YOU AS MUCH FOR
THIS LAST FINAL PANEL I BELIEVE
OR DO WE HAVE ONE MORE NO I
THINK WE'RE- I THINK WE COULD-
WE'RE GOING TO GO INTO PUBLIC
COMMENT WE ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END. RIGHT NOW
IT'S NT A WERE AT THE END OF
THIS HEARING. A BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE
THE PHONE NUMBER IS CONNECTED TO
THE COME THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
AND SHOULD ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN
IF YOU ARE WATCHING OVER THE
INTERNET THE NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE BEING ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR SEVEN OPERATOR
YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT OVER THE PHONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE
SEVERAL IN Q. WHICH I LIKE TO GO
TO THE FIRST COMMENT. LET'S
BEGIN EACH UP EATING MENTOR HAS
ONE MINUTE. WE'LL GO FIRST
ONLINE EIGHTY FOUR EIGHT FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS ONLY ON A
BENDER POLITICS IT WAS FIRED WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE THIRTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR REDUCING FORMER
FLUCTUATES ALMOST FULL SHOPPING
IS IN DIRE NEED OF BEYOND THAT
SHOULD TRUST FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS. AND APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY THOUSAND YOUTH YOUNG
ADULTS WOULD BENEFIT THE CREDIT
HISTORICALLY FOSTER YOUTH
EXPERIENCE ALARMING RATE THE
PROMISES OF A TRANSITION OUT OF
CARE FOR CALIFORNIANS TAKING
TAKING GREAT STRIDES TO ADDRESS
THAT. ONE FOR FOSTER YOUTH
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS AFTER
ACTING CARE BEFORE TURNING
TWENTY THREE FOR YOUTH ACCESSING
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING BUT SINCE
THE RATE IS EVEN HIGHER 40%
EXPERIENCED SOME OF THE FIRES
ENTERING THE PROGRAM SH THE
CALIFORNIA FOSTER YOUTH TAX
CREDIT IS AFFECTED STRATEGY TO.
TALK TO YOU DURING THE CAMPAIGN
I AM SURELY MAKE THE STATE ARE.
TRANSITION TO YOUNG ADULTHOOD
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT COMMENT TO
STREAMLINE. EIGHTY FIVE EIGHT
FIVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH OF THE-
WITH THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE
ACCESS BECAUSE- WE COULD SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REQUEST
FOR FUNDS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION THE FBI OUTREACH
EDUCATION EFFORT. THIS IS
STUDENT LOANS BORROWERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA NOW IS THE UNIQUE AND
CRITICAL CRIED FOR STUDENT LOAN
BORROWERS WITH FEDERAL FEDERAL
STUDENT LOAN PAYMENTS SCHEDULED
TO RESUME ON MAY FIRST FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN TWO YEARS AND ARE
SIGNIFICANT SHIFTS IN STUDENT
LOAN SERVICING COMPANIES THAT
WILL RESULT IN OVER THIRD OF
CALIFORNIA BORROWERS
EXPERIENCING A CHANGE IN SERVICE
ARE BEFORE THE END OF THE YEAR.
ON TOP OF THAT THERE IS ONGOING
TRAINING LIMITED OPPORTUNITIES
FOR PUBLIC SERVICE EMPLOYEES TO
MARK EASILY ACCESS STUDENT DEBT
FORGIVENESS THROUGH OCTOBER OF
THIS YEAR INVESTMENTS IN THE FBI
OUT REGION SUPPORT FOR BORROWERS
WILL PLAY WILL PAY OFF FOR
BORROWERS AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE. STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
THAT JUST A CLARITY THOSE ON
LINE LAST ISSUE WAS ISSUE SOTO
OF FOR KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
RELATED TO BUDGETS OF FOUR THANK
YOU. AB LINE EIGHTY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME IS
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT THE YOUNG
BEHALF OF YOUNG WOMEN BECAUSE
LAST YEAR IN SUPPORT OF STUDENT
LOAN BORROWERS. I CAN BUT I
CAN'T BUDGETS UP YOU CAN KNOTS
FOR WE'RE GOING TO GO ON TO THE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE PLEASE KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS AND TESTIMONY TO
ONE MINUTE. AND ONLY RELATED TO
BUDGETS OF FOUR THANK YOU. WE
HAVE LINE AT. NINETY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS MARK'S
BEVERAGE OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP WE ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE GOVERNMENT'S
INVESTMENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND WE'RE EVEN MORE SUPPORT OF-
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WICKS INTEREST IN
HAVING A LONG TERM INVESTMENT IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. WITH RESPECT
TO THIS YEAR'S BUDGET SO WE JUST
THINK THAT THERE ARE TOO MANY
GAPS IN IN THE PROPOSED
GOVERNMENT BUDGET THE TWO MAIN
PROGRAMS THAT WE ARE USING TO
FUND AFFORDABLE HOUSING FINANCE
DEBATE THE MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
PROGRAM THE CALIFORNIA HELPING
ACCELERATOR- HAVE BOTH NOT BEEN
INCLUDING FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
WE THINK THAT'S AN OVERSIGHT-
THAT IS THE BUT NOT MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING PROGRAM IS QUICKLY
RUNNING OUT OF MONEY FROM
PROPOSITION ONE. AND WE'RE
PROBABLY CANNOT COUNT ON THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S BRINGING IN
NEW RESOURCES TO- TO REPLACE THE
HOUSING ACCELERATOR RESOURCES WE
NEED TO RENEW THOSE AGAIN AS
WELL THIS YEAR SO WE ARE VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT OF AN EXTRA
COMMITTEE APPROVING FINANCING
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR MHP AND HOW
THE ACCELERATOR. AND LASTLY- WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE ADDITIONAL
STAFF RESOURCES FOR BOTH THE TAX
CREDIT COMMITTEE AND THE DEBT
LIMIT ALLOCATION COMMITTEE AND
THEIR PROGRAMS HAVE GROWN STAFF
IS REALLY STRUGGLING TO KEEP UP
IN THOSE RESOURCES WILL REALLY
HELP MAKE THOSE PROGRAMS RUN.
EVEN MORE EFFICIENTLY THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU CALLER. WELL
I. NINETY FIVE. HELLO YEP PLEASE
GO AHEAD NINETY FIVE. I'M SORRY
I DID NOT MEAN THAT IT SHOULD
MEMBERS SPEAKERS WITH THE
STRATEGY ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF GOVERNMENTS CALLED INTO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY PROPOSALS
SHOULD BE INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANT PROGRAM. HOWEVER WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTED A YEAR
MAYBE CONSIDER AUGMENTING THE
PROPOSAL WITH INCREASE FUNDING
FOR THE PROGRAM AS WELL AS
CREATE A TECHNICAL SYSTEM
COMPONENT TO HELP LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WITH POPULATIONS
OF OTHER CHILDREN FIFTY FIVE FOR
THE GRANT. THE INFILL GRANT
PROGRAMS THAT COULD BE
BENEFICIAL TO STAGGER SIX OF
THEM BY PUTTING TO BUILD
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED TO COMBAT
NEW HOUSING PROJECT FOR BROWSING
ADDITIONALLY THE FUNDING
PRIORITIZE GROWTH NEAR TRANSIT
WHICH PRODUCES THE COLD BENEFIT
OF IMPLEMENTING THE LAND USE
STRATEGIES TO HELP US ACHIEVE
OUR GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
TARGETS FOR THESE REASONS. CLICK
QUESTION SUPPORT. OF THE PROGRAM
LOG EDUCATION IMMIGRATION
CHEMICAL SYSTEMS COMPONENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT HAVE
BLINDS. SIX HELLO MY NAME IS
DRAGANA MORALIS WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY BE WORK WITH
LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN EAST COACHELLA VALLEY AT
THESE COMMUNITIES HAVE
EXPERIENCED DECADES OF NEGLECT
AND DISINVESTMENT IN BASIC
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH HAVE A
DIRECT IMPACT ON THE DEVELOPMENT
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE ALSO
WANT TO ADDRESS THE DISPARITIES
IN GEOGRAPHIC DISTRIBUTION OF
STATE. SIGNIFICAN DISCREPANCY IN
THE NUMBER OF PROJECTS AWARDED
IN COASTAL MEGA URBAN REGIONS
VERSUS THOSE INLAND AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES WE ARE STILL
ACTUALLY TRIED TO MAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION BY ENSURING GEOGRAPHIC
EQUITY ACROSS FUNDING PROGRAMS
TARGETED SUPPORT FOR MOBILE HOME
PARK COMMUNITIES. AND IMPROVING
CLIMATE RESILIENCY INVESTING IN
INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES IN
EXISTING RURAL COMMUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FUNDING FOR YOUTH ACTION
PREVENTION PROGRAMS. AND WE ALSO
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE
THAT PROPOSED INVESTMENTS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AN INFILL
AREAS ARE INCLUSIVE OF SMALL
CITIES AND RURAL COMMUNITIES.
AND HAVE AFFORDABILITY
PROTECTIONS THANK YOU. AND NEXT
WE WILL GO TO LINE NINETY TWO.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND I'M SURE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE DOESN'T
MATTER THAT WOULD HAVE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
INTERSTATE RIGHT IT'S ONLY IT'S
ENOUGH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL- TO
TESTIFY ON ISSUE THREE THE
GOVERNOR THOUSAND PROPOSAL.
WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THE
GOVERNMENT'S APPROACH TO
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS AND
AFFORDABLE RENTAL PROGRAM- YOU
SEE THESE AS PART OF THAT-
HOUSING SPECTRUM AND THAT WE-
WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST AND- WERE
DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THAT THAT
GOVERNOR GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
DOESN'T INCLUDE ANY FUNDING FOR
THE PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
PEAK RESTRICTED. HOMEOWNERSHIP
UNITS WHICH- WOULD BE AN ADDRESS
THE RACIAL WEALTH GAP. WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO THE LEGISLATIVE
LEADERS ARE HELPING US MOVE OUR
BUDGET REQUEST FORWARD- I WOULD
LIKE TO ENCOURAGE ME- COMMITTEE
TO INCLUDE OWNERSHIP FUNDING-
AFFORDABLE HOMEOWNERSHIP. OKAY
THANK YOU. FIND OUT WHY HUNDRED
ONE. HELLO MY NAME IS ANDREA
CHAPMAN OF THE OF UNITY CARE FOR
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS UNITS PROVIDE
HOUSING AND SUPPORT SERVICES TO
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
ACROSS NORTHERN CALIFORNIA I'M
HERE TO EXPRESS THE URGENCY FOR
ADDING THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN SUPPORT OF THE FORMER
FOSTER HOMES WITH A VOTE TO
REDUCE THE IMPACT YOUTH AND
YOUNG ADULT ACTING UP OSCARS.
EVERY YEAR TO THE STREET WE KNOW
THAT YOU ARE THE SIGNAL PATHWAY
HOMELESS POPULATION THE FACT
THAT WHEN PUBLISHED IN INTERNET
PRISON SYSTEM AND THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF DISPARITY WITH AFRICAN
AMERICANS MAKING UP FOR THE FIVE
TIMES THE GENERAL POPULATION. WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT AND WE'RE HOPING THAT
YOU WILL SUPPORT THIS INITIATIVE. IN THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU. A
LINE AT. NINETY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME AT THE
MONTERREY COOLEY AND I'M WITH
JOHN BUT NOT FOR YOU I'M HERE
TO. ONE ONGOING INVESTMENT OF
THIRTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE REDUCING FORMER FOX YOU COME
WITH THE PROPOSAL. IN ADDITION
TO ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS AMONG
THE BROADER POPULATION AND USE
WE NEED TARGETED APPROACHES FOR
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH WHO
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS AT MUCH
HIGHER RATE. FIFTEEN H. TWENTY
ONE TWENTY THREE ONE IN FOUR
USED EXPERIENCE PUBLIC THAT
AFTER LEAVING FOSTER CARE.
SPECIFICALLY WERE ASKING FOR AN
ANNUAL INVESTMENT OF THIRTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS TO INCREASE THE
BUDGET FOR THE TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM AND HOUSING
NAVIGATORS PROGRAM BOTH
MINISTERS BY H. T. T. THESE
PROGRAMS ARE PRIORITIZE FOR
YOUTH IN. FOSTER CARE AND ARE
CRITICAL RESOURCES THANK YOU FOR
THE INVESTMENT IN THE PROGRAM TO
DATE WE ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE TO
PREVENT CHRONIC ADULT
HOMELESSNESS BY INVESTING IN THE
POPULATION AND FUNDING THE
THIRTY FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
REDUCING FORMER FOX YOU. HELP
WITH THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALIGNMENT NINETY
EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BRUCE FAMILY YOUNG AND I'M WITH
YOU ALTERNATIVE WE PROVIDE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND
I AM HERE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
THE THIRTY FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
REDUCING FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL I HOPE.
THAT YOU GUYS- ADVOCATE THE BEST
SUPPORTER AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK LINE THAT ONE
HUNDRED FOUR POINT A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION FOR THOSE CALLING
IN WE ARE STICKING TO THE AGENDA
THAT WE HAVE DISCUSSED TODAY.
PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT YOUR
COMMENTS ARE RELATED TO THE
AGENDA DISCUSSED TODAY AND
BUDGETS OF FOUR THANK YOU. I
KNOW ONE HUNDRED FOR YOUR MIKE
ITSELF BUT- GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IS
MY NAME IS ADEOLA MELANIE I'M
WITH JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR
YOUTH WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
ESTABLISHING A LONG TERM ON
GOING FUNDING FOR THE HALF
PROGRAM WHICH CURRENTLY INCLUDES
A SUCCESSFUL YOU THAT ASIDE. JBS
ABOUT THREE REPORT ANALYZING THE
IMPACT OF THE U. SATISFIED IN
BOTH KEEP HAPPY AND WE FOUND AT
THE FEDEX THAT APPROACHES BEEN
EFFECTIVE FOR SEVERAL REASONS IF
INCREASE IMPACT MANY
HOMELESSNESS. INTEGRATED YOUTH
INTO LOCAL ALMOST RESPONSE
NETWORK IT INCREASED LOCAL
UNDERSTANDING AND AWARENESS OF
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS IS EXPANDED
THE CONTINUUM OF HOUSING OPTIONS
FOR YOU. AND LASTLY LOCAL
COMMUNITY. SUPPORT YOU'RE
SATISFIED. SHE THANK YOU FOR THE
TREMENDOUS. TO DATE AND FOR
BEING A CHEN FOR TWO. YOU CAN BE
ON THE- WE ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO BUILD MUCH
MOMENTUM AND CONSIDER HOW WE CAN
CONTINUE THESE IMPORTANT
INVESTMENTS. MOVING FORWARD BY
MAKING THEM ON GOING. LINE ONE
HUNDRED SIX. HI VERY OF A DEAL
STAFF ATTORNEY WITH THE PUBLIC
COUNSEL IN THE CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
PROJECT WE PROVIDE LEGAL
SERVICES TO CURRENT AND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH MANAGER TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE THIRTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR REDUCING FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH HOMELESSNESS
PROPOSAL WHICH WOULD DRASTICALLY
REDUCE HOMELESSNESS AMONG YOUTH
FOR MOVING INTERSTATE PROCTOR
CARE SYSTEM. MANY OF THE FORMER
YOUTH WE WORK WITH ARE
STRUGGLING TO FIND HOUSING BUT A
LONG LONG TERM HOUSING WITHOUT
HELPING OUR CLIENTS ARE THERE
ANY WHAT TO THINK IT'S GOING TO
WORK I MEAN I CAN GET YOU OFF
THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE AN
AGENDA TODAY FOR FOSTER YOUTH
HOUSING WE'RE GOING TO STICK TO
THE AGENDA THAT WE ARE
DISCUSSING TODAY AND SO FORTH
THANK YOU IF YOU ARE CALLING
ABOUT SOMETHING THAT HAS ALREADY
OCCURRED IN THE. PREVIOUS- BUT
HEARING. SUBMIT YOUR- TESTIMONY
VIA EMAIL WE ARE STICKING TO
ONLY THE AGENDA ITEMS DISCUSSED
TODAY THANK YOU ONE MINUTE FOR
EACH TESTIMONY. AND NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED FIVE. BUT
BACK TO CONSULT WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER JUST.
ECHO IN A PREVIOUS STATEMENT I
BECAUSE FORTY FOUR MILLION FOUR
REDUCING FROM ABOUT TWO YEARS-
HUH BUT- AGAIN WE ARE NOT TAKING
ANY COMMENTARY RELATED TO ANY
FOSTER YOUTH HOUSING THAT WAS
NOT ON THE AGENDA FOR TODAY IF
YOU ARE CALLING FOR THAT WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY PLEASE
SUBMITTED THROUGH. EMAIL AND
BUDGETS OF FOUR AND ASM DOT CA
DOT GOP. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
ONE MINUTE PLEASE. AT THE
REMINDER IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
WITHDRAW FROM THE PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU YOU CAN DO SO BY PRESSING
ONE END ZERO AGAIN. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED ONE
HUNDRED THREE. IN ONE HUNDRED
THREE OR MY COULD OPEN. THEY
DISCONNECTED US NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND- GOOD
AFTERNOON MARINO MINE AT THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS FOR THIS
ROBUST DISCUSSION TODAY ON THE
STATE'S HOUSING EVEN YOUR
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING THE
STATE'S HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
HOMELES CHALLENGES. WE SUPPORT
SEVERAL PROPOSALS AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDING THE
DOCK ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
THE STATE ON THE MAP IN TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM AND THE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT IN DIE IGN
EIGHT SECOND PORTFOLIO
REINVESTMENT PROGRAM BUT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK. ELIGIBILITY
FOR THE FOUR FALLING OVER
INVESTMENT PROGRAM TO BE
EXPANDED TO ENSURE THAT ALL EACH
CD FUNDED PROJECT THEY'RE IN
NEED OF INVESTMENT IN QUALIFY
ANY DISNEY ARGUE TO COMMIT A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FUNDING
FROM THIS YEAR'S BUDGET FOR THE
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING PROGRAM AND
CALIFORNIA HOW THE ACCELERATOR
PROGRAM- AND I WOULD ECHO THE
REMARKS THAT I COLLEAGUES.
RETURNED EARLIER AS TO THE NEED
FOR I DID THAT VITAL INVESTMENT
WITHOUT WHICH THAT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PIPELINE VOEPEL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND THAT WILL BE
ABLE GO TO LINE HUNDRED NINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARILLO AND
ASSEMBLY MY NAME'S DAVID CON
BASIC MEMBER THE CITY OF MORE
PARK IN VENTURA COUNTY A MEMBER
OF THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS
REGIONAL COUNCIL WE DID
SOMETHING VERY DIFFERENT THIS
HAVE ONE POINT THREE MILLION
HOMES ALLOCATE TO OUR- HUNDRED
NINETY ONE CITIES IN SIX
COUNTIES. HOW WE CHOSE THIS YEAR
TO ALLOCATE A WORKSHOP CENTERS
AND TRANSIT CENTERS ARE INSTEAD
OF THE PERIPHERY OF METROPOLITAN
AREA THAT MEANS WHERE ARE
PUTTING A LOT OF ALLOCATION TO
BUILD OUT CITIES AND THAT MEANS
THAT THERE'S GONNA BE A LOT OF
DEMAND FOR INFILL PROJECTS
COMING ALONG. AND THAT'S WHY I'D
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
INCREASING THE FUNDING TO THE
INTEL INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED TWELVE. LINE
ONE HUNDRED TWELVE HAD
DISCONNECTED AND THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THAT TIME.
THANK YOU I'M INTEROPERATE ALL
THE TESTIMONY CALLING IN AND
AGAIN WE DO WANT TO KEEP IT TO
THE AGENDA DISCUSSED MY
APOLOGIES FOR THOSE THAT WANT TO
COLIN FOR EITHER PEVIOUS AGENDA
ITEMS OR FUTURE AGENDA ITEMS OR-
ITEMS RELATED TO ANOTHER SUB
COMMITTEE WE HAVE TO KEEP IT
FOCUSED. ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
SUBCOMMITTEE FORMED THE AGENDAS
DISCUSSED FOR TODAY SO
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOU CALLING
AND THANK YOU TO OUR BUDGET
STAFF AND EVERYONE INVOLVED INTO
ALL OUR ANALYST. THIS IS A
BUDGET HEARING IS ADJOURNED.